Zwei Sprechstunden.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Chaos Radio hier auf Fritz. Am letzten Donnerstag im Monat findet es immer statt, das im Blue Moon Leute vom Chaos Computer Club das Studio entern und man könnte fast sagen übernehmen und dann dafür sorgen, dass sie ein bisschen aufgeklärt werden über ein technisches Problem ihrer Wahl. Falls ihr euch übrigens fragt, weil ihr treue Hörer des Chaos Radios seid, was denn mit dieser komischen neuen Musik ist, die hier also die war ja noch nie. Und was ist denn das überhaupt? Die ist von Alec Empire, die hat ja anlässlich des 30C3 geschrieben, des letzten Chaos Communication Congresses. Und die hat den Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club so gut gefallen, dass sie gesagt haben, so die machen wir jetzt mal als neuen Opener im Chaos Radio. Der andere Song war ja auch schon lange genug dabei. So, damit aber genug der Hausmeister rein, kommen wir zum eigentlichen Thema, zu dem ich erstmal unsere Gäste begrüße. Das ist heute Abend Erdgeist. Hallo und guten Abend.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Und Dmitry, hallo, guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und wir sprechen heute über Eigenhosting. Damit kann man viele unangenehme Wortspiele machen, zum Beispiel Eigenhost Stink oder Eigenhost Therapie. Aber es bedeutet letztendlich, dass man sich selber darum kümmert, dass bestimmte Dienste, die man benutzt, die wir alle alltäglich benutzen, nicht bei irgendjemand da draußen im Internet, sondern halt sich selbst darum kümmert.
Warum man das machen sollte? Ich hab meine Daten total gerne erst mal verfügbar. Also ich würde total gerne in 20 Jahren zurückblicken und würde sagen, dass meine Fotos von den Dingen, die ich während meiner Jugend gemacht habe, nicht irgendwo in den Vereinigten Staaten, in einem Rechenzentrum bei einem Dienst liegen, wo ich nicht weiß, ob es den in 20 Jahren noch gibt, um dann vielleicht irgendwie da zu betteln oder das dann noch durch Zufall aus irgendwelchen Backups zu kratzen, sondern ich hätte diese Daten total gerne bei mir und ich fühle mich auch unwohl, dass andere Leute die Option haben, in meinen privaten Fotos herumzuwühlen, die Administratoren in diesen Firmen sind, deren Dienst ich benutze.
Und man hört es ja auch immer wieder, also möglicherweise habt ihr im vergangenen Jahr, kann man ja beinahe sagen, mitbekommen, dass da so gewisse staatliche Stellen in Daten herumlesen, hat man ja gehört, so ein bisschen, glaube ich, oder?
Äh, echt?
Ja, so NSA und so, und GHCQ, also der...
Der NSA, das war da diese Nazis, die da rumgezogen sind.
Äh, äh, nicht? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Erstens Erdgeist, nein. Zweitens, keine Hitler-Scherze. Drittens Erdgeist, nein. Und viertens, kein Gottwinn in dieser Sendung, bitte. Es ist schon so schwer genug, euch im Zaun zu halten. Das muss doch nicht auch noch sein.
Aber ja, auch die NSA, aber auch in den letzten Jahren ist bekannt oder im letzten Jahr ist bekannt geworden, dass bei vielen Anbietern so Passwörter weggekommen sind, dass die Administratoren da gerne mal rumgepumpt haben in den Daten. Es muss halt nicht immer nur der Staat sein, sondern auch die Firmen, die dir den Dienst anbieten, die Daten bei ihnen kostenlos hinzulegen und da kein Geld für haben wollen. Die müssen es irgendwann irgendwie monetarisieren. Und was bleibt ihnen da anderes übrig als dir entweder Werbung einzuspielen oder Informationen über dich oder von dir angehen, anders zu verkaufen zur Begutachtung?
Und das ist auch immer so ein Anfang, der dann auch noch weiterführen kann. Also man weiß ja zum Beispiel, wenn man Google Mail benutzt. Dann hat man es möglicherweise schon mal festgestellt. Man mailt mit den Eltern und erhält sie und sagt so hier, ich hab mir jetzt einen neuen Kleiderschrank gekauft. Dann taucht es rechts sozusagen in dieser Seitenleiste, taucht dann auf ja hier Kleiderschränke kaufen sie, kaufen sie voll super. Das geht ja nur, das kann Google ja nur wissen, indem es in die Mails reinguckt. Und dieses Thema ist schon so alt wie Google Mail selbst. Und die haben gesagt, ja das sind aber nur Algorithmen und die gucken nur rein wegen der Werbung. Das passiert überhaupt nicht. Dann ist neulich rumgekommen, dass Microsoft war es glaube ich, die hatten einen Leaking Fall und haben dann mal also A in dem Mailkonto bei ihrem Angestellten reingeguckt, also was schon fisch ist, also wo man sich streiten kann, weil es der Angestellte von Microsoft ist und der hat böses Zeug gemacht. Aber was sie dann auch noch gemacht haben, sie haben in das Mailkonto eines Bloggers hineingeschaut und das sollte man möglicherweise vielleicht nicht tun.
Nein, das sollte man nicht tun. Hör auf, das zu relativieren. Wenn du dich verantwortlich fühlst für die E-Mails von Leuten, wenn du dich verantwortlich fühlst für Nachrichten, die andere Leute unter der Annahme, dass da kein Schindler mitgetrieben wird, dir diese Daten anvertrauen, dann solltest du einfach mal die Finger davon lassen und es sollte einfach keinen Grund geben, dass da irgendjemand Fremdes dort in den Nachrichten, die dir anvertraut worden sind, rumfunschend darf.
Und es ist im Rahmen dieser Nachrichten rausgekommen, dass es alle großen E-Mail-Dienste tun. Also bei Heise gab es eine Schlagzeile irgendwie Yahoo, Google, Microsoft. Das sind ja die großen quasi. Die gucken da alle rein. Ich persönlich weiß das nicht von Gmx. Das würde mich nicht überraschen, wenn die das alle machen. Aber ich kann es nicht wissen. Und was auch noch schön in diese Reihe hineinpasst, ist eine Schlagzeile, die ich auf netzpolitik.org gesehen habe. Weil die Firmen haben ja früher gesagt, als es rauskam mit Snowden, die ganzen Enthüllungen, haben sie gesagt, wir wussten davon nichts, dass die NSE, also wir wussten davon nichts, dass irgendein NSE-Oberrat fallen lassen. Die wussten das schon alle.
Natürlich, irgendwann ist dabei denen auch die Geduld am Ende, dass immer der Boomer dargestellt werden. Und es sind da ja auch Informationen, so Dokumente geleakt, wie viel Geld diese, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer das jetzt war. Ich glaube, war das Microsoft? Die mit Hotmail irgendwie so Preislisten ausgelegt haben, was da die Zugriffe auf die E-Mails kosten. Aber schon starke Sindiz dafür, dass so sämtliches Vertrauen in so Dienste anbietet, die, wie gesagt, das erstens kostenlos, zweitens dann auch in einer Juristikation, die uns sehr fremd ist und wo wir im Zweifel nicht die Möglichkeit haben, uns mal eben einen Anwalt zu nehmen, dann aber auch aufgrund von welcher Rechtsgrundlage diese Daten da wieder zurück zu bekommen oder uns doll zu beschweren, dass da jemand unsere Daten reinguckt. Ich kann es mir nur schwellig vorstellen, so Google, wenn die da irgendwas Böses mitmachen, was soll ich jetzt tun? Ich habe mit denen keinen gültigen Vertrag, den ich dort, auf den ich pochen dürfte, um überhaupt nur an meine Daten wieder ranzukommen. Und das einzige Versprechen von denen ist, ja, wir haben da den Service, du darfst ihn irgendwie benutzen, solange du da nichts Böses mitmachst, aber ansonsten hast du keinerlei Ansprüche. Und das finde ich ein sehr schwaches Versprechen für mich jetzt, um dort irgendwelche vitalen oder mir nur irgendwie lieben Informationen zu lassen, an die ich später wieder ran will.
Und das ist, könnte man beinahe sagen, der offensichtliche Fall. Man hat die großen Anbieter, man denkt da so, okay, E-Mails, aber was ganz viele Leute benutzen. Und ich glaube, da wird gar nicht mehr drüber nachgedacht, dass wenn sie ein Smartphone haben, dann werden ja irgendwie ihre Kontakte und Kalendardaten synchronisiert. Und das geschieht halt meistens über den Service eines solchen großen Anbieters. Und ich glaube, das ist noch viel weiter in den Hintergrund gerückt.
Manchmal auch gegen deinen Willen. Also ich hatte mit meinem Telefon die Freude, dass dort in jedem Update mir mein Telefon eingestellt hat, dass er die Daten doch mal gerne zu Google schicken möchte. Und ich sagte mal wieder nein und irgendwann habe ich dieses Nein-Hackchen vergessen. Schwups, waren die Daten bei Google. Und auf meinem Mac war genau dasselbe. Ich wollte da einfach nur meine Kontakte mit meinem eigenen Kontakte-Server synchronisieren. Hab dann dieses, hieß dann iCloud-Knöpfchen angemacht. Schwups waren alle meine Daten in der iCloud. Also sprich alle meine Kontaktdaten in der iCloud. Ich hatte rote Ohren und als ich es ausgeschaltet habe, hat er mich gefragt, ob er die Daten jetzt von meinem Computer löschen soll.
Ja, ähm, Entschuldigung, war das nicht? Sollte das nicht eigentlich? So, das sind also die, nennen wir sie mal inhaltlichen Gründe. Haben eigentlich die anderen beiden Herren noch etwas hinzuzufügen?
Ähm, ich würde einfach dazu sagen, so ein Service, der einfach, einfach so zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Was spricht denn dagegen, wenn da einfach mal sonntags ausfällt und du brauchst jetzt unbedingt deine Mails, weil du willst unbedingt mit irgendjemand kommunizieren, und das ist ganz wichtig. Und dann sitzt du einfach da und kannst sagen, okay, sind meine Mails halt gerade weg. Also muss ich jetzt warten, bis es wieder geht, weil die Cloud regnet gerade und wieso auch immer geht es halt nicht. Und dann sitzt du halt da total hilflos und weißt überhaupt nichts davon und hoffst halt, dass wegen deine Daten wiederkommen, wenn überhaupt und nicht irgendwie der Anbieterhobs genommen wurde oder gesagt hat, wir machen das jetzt einfach nicht mehr, weil du bist uns egal.
Dmitry?
Ja, also ich würde noch vielleicht hinzufügen, dass zum Beispiel mein aktuelles iPhone zu aktivieren, muss man ebenfalls einen Apple-Account, also einen iCloud-Account irgendwie haben. Und solange man diese Services nutzt und unterstützt, dann könnte ich mir in fernere Zukunft schon irgendwann vorstellen, dass es extrem schwer gemacht wird, irgendeinen Mail-Service zu benutzen, außer der, der mit deinem Handy oder sonst was ausgeliefert wird.
Also dass es zwar jetzt noch nicht so ist, aber dass man immer, sagen wir, je länger die Zeit freiget, dass man immer weiter in so einen umzäunten Garten halt reinkommt. Wo man halt einfach dann gar nicht mehr rausbrechen kann. Es gibt aber auch noch eine ganz andere Motivation, um seine eigenen Online-Dienste zu betreiben.
Einfach, weil es Spaß macht, weil man mit eigenem Server mal rumbasteln kann, ausprobieren.
Eine dicke, fette Leitung, die wir im Internet platt machen können.
Dazu kommen wir später. Ich meinte jetzt tatsächlich erst mal den Bastelspaß. Also ich hab es tatsächlich selber auch mal ausprobiert und kann sagen, also das erhebende Gefühl, wenn die Dateien auf den eigenen Server synchronisiert werden. Das ist schon geil. Also das ist schon so dieses, jetzt hat man was geschafft. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ähnlich ist wie Autobastler, wenn es dann zum ersten Mal fährt oder so.
Aber das tropft dem Markus gerade ein Freudentränchen.
Ja, ich gebe zu, das macht Spaß.
Na, das ist schon ein tolles Gefühl, wenn du so einen Kalendereintrag auf deinem Telefon einlegst und plötzlich eine Sekunde später ist das ganz ohne iCloud und Google-Kalender auf deinem Rechner und das tut halt einfach.
Und das ist passiert durch das kleine Plastikkistchen unterm Schreibtisch. Das ist nämlich der andere Punkt. Wir wollen uns heute tatsächlich auch damit beschäftigen, weil diese ganze Sache, also ich nehme meinen eigenen Service und betreibe den selber für mich, dass das mittlerweile so billig geworden ist, dass man, ist es nicht umsonst, aber es ist finanzierbar. Da reden wir auch gleich noch um einen Teil drüber.
Das ist billiger als deine DSL-Leitung zu Hause.
Ja, die sollte man aber nicht abschaffen. Nicht, dass es Missverständnis versteht. DSL-Leitung ist trotzdem immer eine gute Idee. So, wir werden also jetzt im Laufe der Sendung, bis Mitternacht noch darüber reden, was man braucht, um selber solche Dienste zu haben, zu benutzen und zu betreiben, was auch Fallstricke sind und wo man sich vielleicht doch lieber für was anderes entscheiden könnte und was man dafür braucht. Und in der ganzen Zeit, falls ihr Geschichten dazu habt oder falls ihr einen bestimmten Service, den wir hier erwähnen oder den wir nicht erwähnt haben, auch auf der Zunge habt und mal was drüber sagen wollt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer, wenn ihr mögt. So, wir haben jetzt ganz lange darüber geredet, warum man denn möglicherweise es für eine total super Idee halten könnte, eigens selber Daten zu betreiben. Also sowas wie ein Mailserver, sowas wie Kontakte oder Kalenderdaten zu synchronisieren. Oder, das haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt, auch Dateien. Also Dropbox ist ja quasi in aller Munde. Man hat einen Ordner auf seinem Rechner, wirft da Dateien rein. Das wird in alle anderen Ordner auch synchronisiert. Und man hat es auch noch im Internet zur Verfügung. Also bei einem amerikanischen Anbieter, der mit seinen Daten macht, was man will und der auch reinguckt.
Es ist im Internet verfügbar.
Für alle. So, und der erste wichtige Punkt, den man verstehen muss für das Betreiben eines eigenen Dienstes. Und ich glaube, das ist für manche Leute auch eine Überraschung. Die Nerds, also die hochnäsigen Nerds, werden jetzt gleich die Augen verdrehen, wenn ich das sage, aber ich glaube, das hätte vielen Leuten noch nicht klar, was ihr im Internet macht. Das sind letztendlich Computer, auf denen Software läuft. Das muss man sich mal überlegen. Das ist nicht mehr. Ich finde das schon spannend, weil das Netz und die Dinge, die da passieren, ist ja sozusagen zu einem Großteil fast wie Magie.
Es ist nicht nur Software, die da läuft, sondern es ist so Software, die du auch selber runterladen oder selber schreiben kannst. Das ist meistens gar nicht so. Die kochen alle auch nur mit Wasser. Also diese Software, die da bei denen läuft, ist nicht immer open source, nicht immer verfügbar, aber am Ende ist es wahrscheinlich, wenn es ein sehr erfolgreicher Service ist, ist es einfach nur sehr gut integrierte Software mit einem schick aussehenden und leicht zu bedehenden Benutzerinterface. Und das ist sowieso das einzige Geheimnis, dass da viel Werbung und ein brauchbares Benutzernterface dahinter ist.
Das heißt also, das ist sozusagen ein Online-Service, also eine Dropbox, ein E-Mail-Anbieter, was auch immer zu installieren, ist auf einer abstrakten Ebene auch nicht mehr, als wenn ihr euch einen Rechner kauft, den aufklappt, das Betriebssystem ist da schon fertig installiert und dann werft ihr noch irgendwie die Software braucht, die ihr haben wollt. Abstrakt theoretisch.
Nö, auch praktisch.
Du kannst auf deinem Mobiltelefon die Dienste auch einfach betreiben, wenn du unbedingt willst.
Ja, also es ist schon so, dass wir jetzt nicht zwei Stunden diesem Thema widmen würden, wenn es genauso einfach wäre, wie eine Office-Anwendung auf einem Rechner zu installieren. Oder?
Das wäre schön, wenn es genauso einfach wäre, wie eine Office-Anwendung.
Na ja, mit manchen. Also gerade so, was diese Raspberry Pi-Bewegung so losgetreten hat, ist halt so, na ja, du packst dieses Image und schiebst das einfach auf eine SD-Karte, steckst die rein und dann hast du irgendwie dein Service laufen.
Siehst du, aber dann pumst du ja schon, das nimmt schon wieder so viel vorweg.
Aber da fängt es doch schon an, du musst ja schon mal wissen, was ein Image ist. Also es geht.
Nee, aber es ist alles sehr einfach und ich finde zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir so anschaue, wie man ein Office installiert auf einer Windows-Kiste, das ist schon manchmal komplizierter, als halt so ein How-To im Internet einfach zu befolgen, wo man, wo drauf steht, wie du halt auf deinem Raspberry irgendwas machst.
Genau, aber das ist nämlich der Punkt. Es gibt auch viele Anleitungen im Internet. Also das muss man nicht alles vorab selber können.
Es gibt auch Office-Selbsthilfegruppen, die dir helfen, beim Installieren.
Gibt es das eigentlich schon bei der Volkshochschule Raspberry Pi für Anfänger?
Vielleicht solltet ihr mal einen Kurs anbieten. Also ich, ich, ich fürchte, es wäre ein bisschen weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, wenn man sagen würde, dass das noch einfacher ist, als ein Office zu installieren. Aber man könnte sich vielleicht darauf einigen, dass die Verzweiflung, die man erreicht, wenn man ein Office installiert, durchaus auch dergleichen könnte, wenn eine Raspberry-Pi-Installation schiefgeht. Also das ist sozusagen ungefähr auf dem selben Level.
Bei so einem Office kann man üblicherweise nicht nachgucken. Da gibt es den Quellcode, nicht? Da gibt es die Install-Skripte nicht in Menschen lesbar. Da ist so ein Pi-Installer, da kann man im Zweifel schon noch...
Jetzt hat der Kai ja schon wieder alles vorweggenommen, jetzt gehen wir mal wieder ganz zum Anfang. Wir haben also schon gelernt, man kann sich diese Dinge im Internet, die da im Internet stattfinden, selber betreiben. Das sind nur Computer, auf denen Software läuft. Die erste Frage, die man sich stellen muss, wenn man das wirklich in Angriff nimmt selber, wie macht man das denn am besten? Wie kann man am besten damit rumspielen? Die Frage ist, wo steht denn dieser Computer? Welche verschiedenen Möglichkeiten gibt es denn da, die Herren?
Also es fängt, glaube ich, einfach an von bei einem selbst unterm Schreibtisch oder mit Gaffa an die Heizung geklebt und ein Ladekabel geht rein. Oder das geht auch bis hin zu es ist ein richtiger Server in einem ordentlichen Gehäuse, in einem großen Data Center mit vielen, vielen Gigabit Anbindungen in einer schönen, kühlen Umgebung. Also das kann man halt von ganz klein und zu Hause bis ganz groß und professionell beliebig skalieren.
Aber sozusagen, also der Unterschied ist, ich habe eine Maschine bei mir zu Hause stehen, die einem DSL-Anschluss hängt und ich habe etwas in einem Rechenzentrum, also sagen, gemietet dann wahrscheinlich.
Genau, aber das kommt halt drauf an, was man halt macht, aber das kommt aus Budget an auf die Lust und was man sich da jetzt antun will.
Aber das klassische Beispiel ist, glaube ich, man nimmt einen alten Desktop-Rechner, der sonst einfach rumsteht.
Damit fängt es dann an. Beziehungsweise gerade ist halt diese, ja...
Mut dir, ich installiere mal kurz Linux.
Brauchst du noch deinen alten Arbeitsrechner?
Also man kann sagen, den eigenen Rechner zu Hause nehmen, einen alten. Man kann diese großen im Rechenzentrum nehmen, die sind aber schon relativ teuer. Also braucht man das von Anfang an? So einen ganzen Rechner in einem Rechenzentrum? Das ist doch wahrscheinlich relativ teuer und auch relativ groß.
Na ja, ja. Also wenn du zu Hause so einen Rechner betreibst und den die ganze Zeit auch betreibst, dann kannst du dich auch auf eine Stromrechnung gefasst machen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass du diese Rechenzentrumsrechner einfach nur so zum Jux dort zu teuer bezahlen musst. Sondern die haben auch anzunehmen das Strom- und Kühlungskosten, die du dann zu Hause, die Kühlung wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber dafür kaufst du dann Strom auch nicht so billig ein.
Ja, wenn du in eine Heizung tapest, wie Kai gerade gesagt hat, dann ist das mit der Kühlung wirklicherweise doch auch.
Dann hast du einen Kühlkörper. Aber trotzdem, wenn du so den alten Arbeits-PC von Mama nimmst, so ein, keine Ahnung, Kai Screen, 1995er, dann geht auch. Da kann man schon mal mit rum experimentieren. Aber da würde ich jetzt nicht 24-7 für das ganze Jahr meine Dienste mit betreiben. Also das ist so einer der großen Punkte. Man sollte sich die Rechner, die man sich zu Hause dann so parallel hinstellt, dann auch schon aus Strom-Gesichtskosten und auch aus lautstacke Gesichtspunkten so hinoptimieren, dass man nicht die ganze Zeit von Lüftern genervt wird und dass man nicht von der Stromrechnung überrascht wird.
Also eigentlich hat das einen tollen Lerneffekt, weil das machst du eigentlich in der Regel wie damals mit dem Modem. Du machst es halt einfach, bis die erste Rechnung bei dir aufschlägt und dann siehst du so, oh, da muss ich ja doch was tun. Dann fängst du an plötzlich mal darüber nachzudenken, wo man das optimiert. Das ist so genau der gleiche Lerneffekt, wie wenn dir halt das erste Mal dein Mailserver um die Ohren fliegt oder so.
Also als ich da so alt war, da war das nicht so schlimm. Da konnte man da so als 1912er mit der Hardware, da konnte man noch nicht so viele schlimme Dinge machen heutzutage. Heutzutage, wenn man sein erstes Stück PHP Software dort auf irgendeinem Server betreibt, auch im Internet, dann kann da die gesamte Welt reingucken und dann ist der Server auch noch so ganz dick angebunden und dann passieren da schlimme Dinge.
Na, dafür hast du wahrscheinlich früher mal das Modem über Nacht angelassen und da hast du was gesetzt und...
Also sagen, für die ersten Schritte und gerade, wenn man noch nicht genau weiß, was man macht, ist es also besser, den Rechner zu Hause zu haben.
Ja klar, erstmal willst du ja dann im Zweifel auch direkt den Knopf haben. Also du willst immer wieder an- und ausschalten können, weil du wirst einfach scheitern und du wirst immer wieder Dinge falsch machen. Und du möchtest nicht jedes Mal im Rechenzentrum einen Rebootauftrag, dort einen Administrator losschicken, der dann für dich das Knöpfchen drückt, sondern...
Vor allem hängst du halt einfach irgendwann an der Stelle, halt immer dein Monitor dran zu schauen, was da steht. Und im Data Center siehst du sowas nicht, weil da pingt's oder ist nicht. Also du überreichst den Server oder er tut nicht.
Das muss man vielleicht mal wissen. Also wenn man einen Server sich mietet, dann ist es meistens so, dass man nur über eine Kommandozahle zugreifen kann. Das heißt, man hat dann nur wirklich Textfenster. Und muss sich dann schon relativ gut auskennen. Ich hab das selber ausprobiert und hab mit beiden schon rumgespielt. Tatsächlich, was ihr gerade gesagt habt, ist tatsächlich dieses beruhigende Gefühl, einen Monitor anschließen zu können. Und das ist total absurd eigentlich, weil letztlich macht man da auch nichts anderes, als wenn man sich über die Fernen diesen Rechner einloggt. Aber es hat irgendwie was Beruhigendes, wenn man sozusagen wirklich dabei ist vor Ort. Das ist schon in das Gefallen, das zählt ja auch zu dem Rechner zu Hause. Raspberry Pi sind diese kleinen, erzähl mal, was das ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wo die herkommen. Die waren auf jeden Fall da letztes Jahr. Und ich glaube, war das Crowdfunded, das Projekt oder sowas? Nee, also es ist halt ein kleines Board, wo halt Leute angefangen haben, für einfache Dinge zu entwickeln, wie ein kleines Linux. Das Teil frisst, also kann man an USB-Port betreiben, vom Strom her, zieht halt irgendwie, ja...
Zu vernachlässigen Fällen.
Kaum Strom, also so, als würdest du dein Handy den gesamten Tag am Netzteil halten. So viel Strom zieht es und du hast halt rein einen kompletten Server mit einem Linux, wie auch in einem großen RZ, nur weniger Leistung. Aber du brauchst die Leistung in der Regel ja auch nie.
Das wollte ich gerade mal fragen, kamen diese Rechner irgendwelche Hardware-Anforderungen, wenn man jetzt anfängt mit solchen Sachen?
Also der Raspberry Pi zum Beispiel, der kommt komplett fertig. Da steckt man eine SD-Karte rein und der fährt hoch. Das reicht halt schon für die meisten Dinge aus, aber je nachdem, wo dann die Anforderungen sind, kann das dann halt sein, dass der viel zu schwach ist. Aber das merkt man dann halt früher oder später. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn man so grundsätzlich anfängt, seine erste Webseite darauf programmieren will oder so, dann reicht der wahrscheinlich aus.
Aber es gibt auch andere Embedded Boards. Also es gibt zum Beispiel der Beaglebone, ist vielleicht erwähnungswert. Und ansonsten die nächste Stufe, die ein bisschen mehr, sozusagen ein bisschen dickere CPU hat, ist dann zum Beispiel der Panda Board, den kenne ich. Das ist dann auch ganz nett. Und fast alle diese Projekte, die ein bisschen bekannter sind, haben das, was wir am Anfang schon erwähnt haben, diese Images, die man ohne Einleitung, so dass man eigentlich ohne weiteres einfach im Internet nachschlagen kann, wie man dann ein Betriebssystem darauf installiert.
Images ist an der Stelle einfach nur eine Kopie einer Festplatte oder einer SD, die er braucht, um zu booten, auf der dann das Betriebssystem und schon ein bisschen Software vorinstalliert ist. Und das heißt dann einfach Image. Und das kann man auf einer SD-Karte einfach drauf tun. Wenn man sie reinsteckt, dann erkennt er, ah, das ist eine virtuelle Festplatte, kann ich von booten. So, das ist die ganze Magie hinter den Images. Und die wurden dann von irgendjemanden, der sie hegt und pflegt, schon fertig installiert und weitestgehend getestet, bevor er es ins Internet getan hat, wenn man Glück hat.
Also du kriegst halt eigentlich eine super einfache Anleitung, wo man einfach danach eine voll funktionsfähige Kiste hat, die dann halt irgendwie zum Beispiel, ja, Dateien schert, dein Kalender hat, deine Mails oder sonst was. Und das gibt's halt alles in fertig mit 1A-Anleitungen, die super einfach zu verstehen sind, ohne dass man jetzt sagt, man braucht zehn Jahre Linux-Erfahrung dafür, überhaupt diese Kiste zu booten, sondern ist halt einfach so Webseite lesen, Schritt eins bis zehn befolgen, fertig.
Okay, also wir halten mal fest, für den Anfang reicht es, gerade wenn man anfängt, sich mit diesem Pionier zu beschäftigen, Rechner zu Hause zu haben. Diese, nur noch ganz kurz, dann machen wir erst mal Nachrichten, man kann sie auch wie gesagt rechnen im Rechenzentrum mieten. Das ist ja relativ teuer, wenn man sie jetzt anguckt. Also ein ganzer Rechner, 50 Euro im Monat oder sowas, ist das die Größenordnung, der man sich dann sofort bewegt, oder gibt es das auch ein kleiner?
Na, für dich ist wenig Unterschied, ob du jetzt wirklich einen ganzen Server im Rechenzentrum buchst, oder ob du eine kleine, naja, so eine separierte Box...
Ein 40.
Genau, also wenn du dir diesen Rechner mit vielen anderen Leuten teilen musst, bekommst du ja nicht so richtig mit. Also diese ganzen Betriebssysteme sind ja heutzutage schon eh darauf ausgelegt, dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig darauf eingeloggt sein können, da irgendwie Berechnungen machen. Das kann man natürlich immer noch weiter und weiter virtualisieren, dass du das gar nicht mehr merkst, dass du in Wirklichkeit keinen ganzen Rechner zur Verfügung hast. Und da gibt es auch Rechenzentren, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben, einfach viele Boxen parallel an viele Leute zu vermieten. Und das G kann man noch weiter treiben, dass das EC2 zum Beispiel, dass Amazon anfängt, die ganzen Rechner, die sie da irgendwo rumstehen haben, die in dynamisch-elastischen, ja sie nennen es Cloud-Service, sie sagen einfach, du kannst dich darauf einloggen, du kannst so ein Image auch installieren und dann kannst du dann da drinnen, je nachdem wie viele Ressourcen du da gerade brauchst, über eine Webseite dekonfigurieren.
Das sind dann quasi keine echten Rechner mehr, sondern quasi nur virtuelle. Also du kriegst keine wirkliche Hardware mehr gemietet, sondern Rechenkraft in Höhe von...
Du kannst teilweise auch sogar Minutengenau sagen. Das ist jetzt nichts, was man braucht, aber du wirst halt wirklich für genau den Monat mit genau der Leistung, die du gebraucht hast, abgerechnen. Aber zum Beispiel gibt es auch die ganz andere Seite, es gibt Hoster, da schickst du ein Paket hin mit einem Raspberry Pi und die sagen, for free, weil Strom und so kostet das nichts. Und sobald du dann ein bisschen mehr haben willst, zahlst du irgendwie einen Fünfer, aber da kannst du halt deinen Pi hinschicken und die stecken den halt in eine angenehme Anbindung und mit einer festen IP. Und dann kannst du halt einfach das, was du zu Hause machst, ein Stück professioneller im Internet dann machen.
Okay, aber das ist dann schon für Fortgeschritten. Gut, jetzt wissen wir schon mal, welche Maschinen wir haben und wir werden gleich nochmal drüber reden, wie die angeschlossen sind und vor allen Dingen natürlich auch, was man dann letztendlich raufspielt. Aber bevor wir das machen, gibt es erstmal die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Und jetzt eine ganz persönliche Nachricht von Sean Paul an alle Fritz Freunde.
Wir übersetzen Simultan. Eh, liebe Fritz-Freunde, kommt ab zu meiner Show. Wird bestimmt knorke in Berlin. Ich freu mich auf euch.
Danke. Mai. Jean Paul, live in der Berliner Kolumbiale.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Immer gute neue Musik.
Mit Golo Schmied. Union und SPD haben sich auf einen Gesetzentwurf zur doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft für nicht EU Bürger geeinigt. Kinder, die seit der Geburt neben dem Deutschen auch noch einen anderen Pass besitzen, sollen sich in Zukunft nicht mehr zwischen den beiden Staatsbürgerschaften entscheiden müssen. Voraussetzung ist, dass sie mindestens acht Jahre lang in Deutschland gelebt haben oder sechs Jahre lang eine deutsche Schule besucht haben. Die Regelung gilt auch für Kinder ausländischer Eltern mit einem deutschen Schul- oder Ausbildungsabschluss. Nach dem Nachrichtendienst Twitter hat die türkische Regierung jetzt auch YouTube blockiert. Das melden staatliche Medien des Landes. Auf YouTube waren zuvor Tonaufnahmen aufgetaucht, auf denen angeblich der türkische Außenminister, der Geheimdienstchef und zwei weitere Spitzenbeamte zu hören waren. Die Männer sollen über eine militärische Intervention in Syrien gesprochen haben. Wie YouTube wurde auch Twitter in der Vergangenheit dazu genutzt, um Korruptionsvorwürfe gegen die Regierung von Ministerpräsident Erdogan zu verbreiten. Die UNO-Vollversammlung hat die Eingliederung der Krim durch Russland verurteilt. Für die Erklärung stimmten in New York 100 Staaten, darunter auch Deutschland. 11 Länder waren dagegen, fast 60 enthielten sich. In dem Text wird die internationale Gemeinschaft aufgerufen, keine Veränderung der ukrainischen Grenzen anzuerkennen. Der internationale Währungsfonds hat der Ukraine heute einen 27 Milliarden Kredit versprochen. Dafür müsste das Land aber strenge Sparmaßnahmen durchsetzen. Für Steuerbetrüger wird es künftig teurer und schwieriger, mit einer Selbstanzeige straffrei davonzukommen. Die Finanzminister der Länder haben sich darauf geeinigt, die Regeln für die Selbstanzeige weiter zu verschärfen. Unter anderem soll der Zeitraum zur Offenlegung von 5 auf 10 Jahre verlängert werden. Außerdem sollen die Strafzuschläge auf hinterzogene Summen verdoppelt werden. Es sind aber noch Details offen, sie sollen bis Mai geklärt werden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Schönefeld 5 Spandau 7 Grad, in Neuropin und Bad Freienwalde jeweils 4, Ludwigsfelde 5 und Frankfurt Oder 6 Grad. Heute Nacht kann es Richtung Oder und Neiße noch etwas Regen geben, der Rest von Brandenburg und Berlin bleibt aber trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken auf bis zu 1 Grad. Morgen gibt es dann wieder mehr Regen, nur etwas Sonne bei maximal 16 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Vorsicht auf der A100 Richtung Neukölln-Treptow. Am Dreieck-Punkturm ist die überre Leitung zur A115 Richtung Dreieck-Nutetal gesperrt. Nach Tiergarten, hier ist der Tiergartentunnel bis 5 Uhr früh in Richtung Wedding gesperrt. Und noch zwei Meldungen zur S-Bahn. Bis Betriebsschluss ist die Linie S5 zwischen Lichtenberg und Wuletal unterbrochen. Ihr könnt die U5 nutzen. Außerdem werden zwischen Biesdorf und Wuletal Busse eingesetzt. Die Linien S7 und S75 sind zwischen den Bahnhöfen Springfuhl und Lichtenberg unterbrochen. Ein Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen wird eingerichtet. Davos geht euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club. Das sind heute im Einzelnen der Erdgeist, der Kai und der Dmitry. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Wir sprechen heute über das Eigenhosting. Nein, das ist nichts ekliges, sondern das heißt einfach nur, dass viele Dienste, die im Internet benutzt, da kann man sich auch selber drum kümmern. Man kann also sein eigener Internet, nicht Service Provider, aber Internetdienste, Anbieter sein. Zum Beispiel möglicherweise sowas wie Dropbox. Also man schickt Dateien hin und her und synchronisiert sich vor verschiedenen Rechnern. Und wir haben schon gelernt, das ist eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlimm, denn was auch immer im Internet passiert, ist letztendlich nur ein Computer, auf dem auch nur Software läuft. Und wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde gelernt, man kann sich, gerade wenn man anfängt, sich mit diesem Thema zu beschäftigen, sich am besten so ein kleines Ding zu Hause hinstellen, damit basteln. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel, entweder nimmt man den alten Rechner, die Hardware-Anforderungen sind auch nicht hoch, oder man besorgt sich so einen kleinen Raspberry Pi. Das ist so ein Minicomputer, der war ursprünglich mal für pädagogische Zwecke gedacht, aber da haben sich viele Buster gedacht, hey, wir wollen damit auch spielen und den gibt es für relativ schmales Geld. Also, ich glaube unter 50 Euro ist man dabei.
Das hat gerade mal noch jemand ausgerechnet, dass was der Raspberry Pi so frisst an Strom sind, wenn man ihn die ganze Zeit betreibt, 20 Euro im Jahr. Und ich glaube, kostet 30 Euro im Einkauf.
Okay, ein ganzer Rechner sozusagen. Also wenn man einfach einen alten Desktop-Rechner nimmt und den du betreibst, ist der wahrscheinlich unwesentlich teurer.
Der macht wahrscheinlich so 20, 30 Euro im Monat. Allein weil der glaube ich so was wie 100 Watt zieht, wenn er noch so ein Alter ist.
Also zum Basteln ist so ein kleiner Plastorechner auch sehr gut. Und Dmitry meinte noch, es gibt noch ganz andere Rechner. Habt ihr vergessen, was? Panda?
Panda Board. Aber das sind die, die ein bisschen schneller sind.
Für Fortgeschrittene quasi.
Genau. Aber was auch für einen empfehlenswert ist, weil sie auch sehr viele Erweiterungen bieten, die ein bisschen umfangreicher sind als die Raspberry Pi, sind die sogenannte Beagle Bones.
Beagle Bones.
Und die kosten, meiner Meinung nach, sowas wie 50 Euro. Also nur ein bisschen teurer.
Machen aber auch mehr Spaß.
Beagle Bones, das stelle ich mir so kleine Hunde vor, die... Egal, sind auch Hunde drauf. So, Lars hat angerufen, möchte seinen ersten Erfahrungsbericht beistehen. Das könnt ihr übrigens gerne machen, wenn wir heute Abend Dinge erwähnen, also wenn wir Dinge erwähnen, die ihr nicht versteht, aber denkt, ich würde es aber gerne verstehen, könnt ihr gerne anrufen und nochmal nachfragen. 0331 77 97 120 Oder wenn ihr selbst Erfahrungen mit so einem Dienst, den ihr selber betrieben habt, gemacht habt, könnt ihr auch gerne anrufen. So, Lars, 28 aus Leipzig, guten Tag Lars.
Ja, schönen guten Abend.
Hallo, du hast dich also entschlossen, ein eigenes Ding zu betreiben?
Ja, korrekt. Und zwar, ich habe mir letztes Jahr im Dezember habe ich mir einen neuen Router gekauft, weil ich mich sehr darüber aufgeregt habe, dass Kabel Deutschland doch zwei Euro Aufschlag verlangt für die WLAN-Funktion an ihrem Router.
Ich hab das durchschau'r gehört, ich wollte das gar nicht glauben. Also das ist wirklich so, wenn man da also Internet kauft, dann muss man noch mal extra pro Monat bezahlen, wenn man WLAN haben will.
Das ist korrekt. Ich bin letztes Jahr im September eingezogen, hab irgendwann auf die Kabel Deutschland Rechnung geguckt und hab gedacht, nee, das ist jetzt nicht ernst, dass die zwei Euro mehr verlangen, nur dass sie von der Ferne quasi diese WLAN-Funktion zuschalten.
Das ist ja ganz großartig. Hast du dir deinen eigenen Router gekauft?
Genau, ich hab mir einen TP-Link-Router geholt und hab halt so ein bisschen recherchiert und hab auch extra bei dem Kauf schon darauf geachtet, dass man da auch eine eigene Firmware installieren kann quasi. Genau, und da hab ich halt das OpenBHT gewählt, diese Linux-Distribution für diese embedded device quasi.
Also das ist einfach zu sagen eine Art kleines Betriebssystem für die Plastabox, die das Internet in deiner Wohnung macht. Und also erste Frage natürlich so, eine Firmware selber auf so ein kleines Gerät aufspielen, ist ja so ein bisschen hakelig. Hat das auf Anhieb funktioniert?
Ja, definitiv. Also ich war quasi, man konnte direkt über die Web-Oberfläche von der alten Firmware einspielen. Also es war relativ richtig witzig. Also einfach nur die Datei auswählen, hochladen. Das ist halt so eine Punkt-Bind-Tartei. Und dann kann man direkt das Update machen und zack hat man dann das quasi das abgespeckte Linux, das Open-WRT drauf.
Und war das dann für dich nur ein gutes Gefühl oder hat das tatsächlich auch Vorteile, dass du dieses Ding benutzt hast?
Natürlich, ich hatte das ein gutes Gefühl und Vorteile auch. Also erstmal habe ich viel mehr Macht halt über den Router.
Tu es solange du es noch darfst. Also der Trend geht ja dahin, dass dir die ISPs verbieten wollen, deine eigene Software auf deinem Router zu betreiben, weil so viel Adminstationsaufwand. Dann rufen die alle an mit Kraut und Rüben-Versionen, wo wir nicht wissen, warum es nicht funktioniert. Und ja, da geht der Trend demnächst hin, dass sie dann auch weiter die Kontrolle, die enge Kontrolle über deinen Router haben wollen.
Die wollen immer weiter mein Wohnzimmer, ich weiß.
Genau, aber noch hat's geklappt. Und hast du dann noch, also mal abgesehen vom Router, tatsächlich irgendwas selber noch damit gebastelt? Also Dropbox, E-Mails, was auch immer?
Also ich hab quasi erst mal laut dem Wiki so ein bisschen die Grundinserzungen gemacht. Das war auch nicht ganz so einfach. War schon vieles vorgegeben, aber ein bisschen reinfuchsen musste man sich halt auch schon. Ich kann mich aber auch im Vorfeld auch schon ein bisschen mit Linux aus und jetzt hab ich mir halt so meinen eigenen FTP Server drauf installiert, um mit dem quasi Dropbox zu ersetzen, weil man ja doch schon in der letzten Zeit immer viel Negatives über Dropbox gehört hat, weil wir sind halt USA Server und man weiß nicht so wirklich, was mit den Daten passiert.
Also du auf deinem Router läuft jetzt noch eine kleine Software oder hast du noch mal einen extra Rechner irgendwo hingestellt?
Nee, nee, das läuft direkt auf dem Router. Das ist quasi ein Softwarepaket, das nenne ich PureFTP und den habe ich halt nachinstalliert und habe einfach einen USB-Port, der da dran ist an dem Motor, habe ich quasi eine 640 Gigabit Platte angesteckt und kann jetzt quasi von unterwegs auf die Daten zugreifen.
Jetzt aber FDP heißt ja, du musst dich jedes Mal extra in den Server einloggen oder gibt es da, wie läuft das dann auf deinem Rechner? Wie benutzt du das?
Ja, ich müsste mich theoretisch einloggen. Also ich kann mich mit meinem Tablet halten, mit meinem Telefon einloggen. Ich brauche natürlich die Zugangsdaten und habe natürlich auch darauf geachtet, also anfangs war es noch unverschlüsselt und jetzt, wo er extra noch verfügbar ist, habe ich halt auch noch eine Verschlüsselung mit eingebaut.
Und wie schnell funktioniert das? Also wie dick ist dein Internetanschluss und wie gut funktioniert das, wenn du zeitlich irgendwo bist und dann auf diese Dateien zugreifst, die bei dir zu Hause liegen?
Also es geht einigermaßen. Kabelreschen ist da ein bisschen großzügiger. Also ich hatte vor kurzem noch eine 100 MBit Leitung, da war noch der Upload noch ein bisschen höher. Jetzt hab ich bloß noch eine 32 MBit Leitung, aber hab trotzdem noch, ich sag mal so, 1, 8 MBit noch Upload. Also es geht.
Also das ist sozusagen, wenn man eine bisschen größere Datei runterlädt, dann muss man zwar ein bisschen warten, aber es ist noch nicht doll schlimm.
Ja ich sag mal so Filme streamen und sowas geht jetzt nicht wirklich, aber bei größeren Dateien, es geht auch.
Dann erliere ich jetzt auch mal daraus, dass du halt noch nicht von diesem, kommen wir glaube ich später noch zu, von diesem Carrier Grade Nutter dahinter hängst. Also du hast halt wirklich noch eine echte, von außen erreichbare IP zu Hause dann an deinem Router.
Ja da kommt wieder Kabel Deutschland ins Spiel, die sind ja so, dass die feste IPs vergeben. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht bei dem DNS oder so registriert, dass ich quasi per DNS-Namen drauf gehen kann, sondern ich gehe halt jetzt momentan erst noch direkt über die IP drauf, genau.
Und hast du, planst du noch ein weiteres, das zu erweitern oder bist du jetzt einfach so zufrieden?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Also ich würde schon gerne Mailserver noch drauf machen und halt das, was sich noch so ergibt.
Okay, sehr schön. Also es ist etwas haklich, hast du uns erzählt, aber es funktioniert und es macht Spaß.
Ja, man muss sich halt hier begeistern und ein bisschen was ernüsten.
Alles klar. Lars, dann vielen Dank. Ja, viel Spaß noch. So, also, das finde ich ja sehr schön, wenn ihr noch eine ähnliche Geschichte habt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen, 0331 70 97 110, wenn ihr euer eigener Webmaster seid. Jetzt hat der Lars schon einen Punkt angesprochen, den wir auf jeden Fall auch noch besprechen müssen. Und das ist halt die Sache mit der IP-Adresse. Oder andersrum gesagt, ich stelle, wenn ich, wenn ich irgendwie sowas wie Dropbox, bleib bei mir bei Dropbox benutze, dann gebe ich in meinen Webbrowser einen dropbox.com, dann komme ich auf diese Webseite, kann da irgendwie meine Dateien sehen und runterladen und hochladen, weiß ja gar was. Und wenn ich die App dazu benutze, also vom Rechnerinzeliere, dann kümmert die sich. Wenn ich jetzt einen Rechner zu Hause hinstelle, egal ob bei einem alten Arbeitsrechner oder ein Raspberry Pi oder ein Beaglebone, dann muss ich dem ja irgendwie sagen, wohin er gehen soll. Und jetzt hat der, also wenn ich jetzt von meinem Rechner, wenn ich bin irgendwo im Internet unterwegs, dann denke ich, ich möchte jetzt auf meiner Datei...
Du möchtest ihm nicht sagen, wohin er gehen soll, sondern woher er kommen soll.
Ja, also ich möchte, dass mein Computer, der irgendwo in der Welt unterwegs ist und online ist, eine Verbindung herstellen kann zu dem Rechner, der jetzt zu Hause steht und der meine Services anbietet. Jetzt hat der Lars gerade erzählt, der hätte eine feste IP-Adresse. Das heißt, er kann einfach diese Nummer, ist ja so eine Nummeranfolge, eingeben. Und dann ist die Verbindung hergestellt. Und weil das eine feste IP ist, das heißt, die ändert sich nicht, muss er das nur einmal machen, muss ich diese Nummer nur einmal merken und dann ist gut. Aber bei den meisten von uns ist es ja so, dass wir jeden Tag, also nach dieser 24-Stunden-Zwangstrennung spätestens, eine neue IP-Adresse kriegen mit dem Internetanschluss zu Hause.
Ja, und nicht nur das, der Punkt ist, dass dein Router zu Hause der Einzige ist, der dann diese feste IP-Adresse bekommt und der Rest deiner Geräte zu Hause bekommt aus, ja, so virtuellen Netzwerken, die nicht wirklich im Internet gefunden werden können, bekommt er so eine Adresse, wird dann gemasqueradet. Das heißt, der Router gibt dann für die Verbindungen, die nach draußen gehen, gibt dann seine Adresse an und für die Antworten, die dann aus dem Internet zurückkommen, guckt da wieder nach, welcher der internen Rechner dann derjenige ist, der diese Anfrage gestellt hat. Und diese Rechner sind selber aus dem Internet normalerweise nicht erreichbar, die bei dir zu Hause rumstehen.
Könnte man das mit einer WG vergleichen? Jemand, der sozusagen, jemand, der nicht genau weiß, wo in der WG die Leute sitzen, der schickt das Paket einfach an die Malini DC Allee 20 und dann wird es da abgegeben.
Und dann fragt halt jemand intern so, wer hat denn gerade da ein Paket geholt?
Mit dem Unterschied, dass man den WG jeden Tag ändert.
Genau, die Adresse ändert sich jeden Tag. Morgen ist es dann die so.
Also hast jetzt zwei Probleme zu lösen. Das erste Problem ist, dass deine IP-Adresse sich täglich ändert. Und das zweite Problem ist, dass wenn du von draußen kommst, keine wirkliche Möglichkeit hast, normalerweise einen hinter diesem Router befindlichen Rechner direkt anzusprechen, sondern nur indirekt. Und da gibt's so mehrere Tricks. Der eine Trick ist erst mal, um den Rechner direkt anzusprechen, sogenannt das Port Forwarding. Das bieten so eigentlich alle moderneren Router. Dass du sagst, für alle Verbindungen, die versuchen, einen Web-Server zu erreichen, also auf Port 80 reinkommen, gibt das mal immer ganz fest diesem einen Rechner, der dort sich im internen Netz befindet.
Also, um beim Weggeber Beispiel zu bleiben, wenn jemand kommt und rote Postkarten abgibt, die gehen ins Wohnzimmer zu Erdgeist.
Du meinst die Rechnungen alle. Genau. Das hat aber den Nachteil, dass wenn man da nur eine IP-Adresse hat, dass dann man natürlich auch nur einen einzigen Web-Server auf diesem Port 80 betreiben kann, was der Standardport ist. Für Web-Server, das heißt für alles andere, muss man sich dann schon wieder andere tolle Dinge ausdenken.
Okay, aber das ist dann schon für fortgeschrieben. Und man muss auch dazu sagen, das hört sich jetzt alles so kompliziert an, also von wegen IP-Forwarding und Nat und so weiter. Aber es gibt dafür auch im Netz tatsächlich, also A ist es tatsächlich mittlerweile sehr einfach, die Router, die Benutzeroberflächen in den Routern sind mittlerweile sehr übersichtlich. Also bei den Modellen, die ich kenne, muss ich zumindest sagen. Und es gibt genau dafür Schritt für Schrittanleitung. Und das Ganze lässt sich meistens dadurch beheben oder dadurch machen, dass man das mal kurz nachguckt und dann irgendwie eine Zahl abschreibt und in eine Tabelle einträgt. Und das ist quasi der ganze technische Vorgang, der da passiert.
Ja, noch nicht mal. Also ich hab letztens noch so eine aktuelle Fritzbox drauf geschaut und so ein Rechner schreit heutzutage ja ins Netz, was er für Services anbietet. Und dann hat der Router sich von sich an von sich aus schon angeboten, so ich hab hier gesehen, du hast hier einen Rechner, der macht Folgendes. Klicke hier und dann ist das auch im Internet. Und dann hast du das Nummern abtippen, dir komplett gespart und der kümmert sich auch darum, falls sich die Nummer ändert und so Sachen.
Okay, es geht dann auch noch viel automatischerer. Wenn man heutzutage BitTorrent Software betreibt, auch auf einem der Rechner, dann würde die ja nicht so richtig funktionieren, wenn alle Leute hinter diesen Nuts, also hinter Routern nur sind. Dann könnten sich ja zwei Leute nie peer-to-peer-mäßig verbinden. Also haben dann diese BitTorrent Erfinder, eins der Protokolle, das man benutzt, um mit dem Router zu sprechen, schon dann so weit standardisiert und so weit etabliert, dass man auch aus dem Inneren deines WG-Netzwerks einfach dem Router Bescheid sagen kann, ach ja, wenn jetzt irgendjemand kommt und BitTorrent mit mir sprechen möchte, dann gebt ihm doch mal bitte jetzt ganz dynamisch immer gleich zu mir weiter. Also du kannst bei dir zu Hause Peer-to-Peer machen, weil es eh schon automatisierte Möglichkeiten gibt, auch dem Router dieses Port-for-Warding beizubieten, ohne dass man nur etwas klicken muss. Okay, so.
Ich glaube, das hat mehr verwirrt als...
Das war der Plan.
Aber das ist zu sagen, das ist der zweite Teil. Noch schnell, das andere Ding, was auch immer auf dem Internet zugreift, auf meine Daheim-IP-Adresse, muss er genau wissen, wie diese Adresse ist, wie kläre ich das? Es gibt ja dieses Zauberwort DIN-DNS. Was genau verbirgt sich dahinter? Wie funktioniert es?
Na, es gibt halt das DNS, nennt sich das Domain Name System, was halt eigentlich nichts als ein Telefonbuch ist, wo zum Beispiel, wenn man dann markusrichter.de eingibt, dann weiß dann dieses Telefonbuch, das markusrichter.de, unter der 23.42.5.23 zu erreichen ist. Und jetzt ist nur das Problem, das klappt ganz gut, wenn du halt immer die gleiche IP-Adresse, also immer die gleiche Nummer zu Hause an dein Amtsschluss hast. Nur zum Beispiel, wenn du alle 24 Stunden kriegst, in der Regel so eine neue. Und da gibt es dann so Services, wo dein Router wiederum hingeht und sagt so, ey, ich hab eine neue IP-Adresse, mach das markusrichter.de jetzt nicht auf die 23.42.5.23 läuft, sondern auf die 42 hinten heute. Und am nächsten Tag wieder anders. Und der kümmert sich auf das immer schön Up-to-date. Und das nenne ich dann diese Dynamic DNS. Und da gibt es halt inzwischen einen riesigen Zoo an Anbietern zum Glück.
Und dann kann man sie doch einfach klicken.
Genau, also zum Beispiel wieder das Beispiel Fritzbox zu bringen, weil das hab ich so ein paar Mal in der Hand gehabt jetzt in letzter Zeit. Und da hat es halt inzwischen Fritz AVM selbst gesagt, wir bauen so einen Service. Und da kannst du halt sagen, du möchtest diesen Service nutzen, kannst aus einem Menü auswählen, ich möchte den von AVM nutzen, gibs dann irgendwie ein, das soll markusrichter.fritzbox.de heißen. Und dann heißt die immer so.
Also auch das muss man, ich stelle fest, ganz viele von den Dingen, die man lernt, da muss man einfach nur wissen, dass sie da sind. Dann kann man sozusagen selber reingucken und das machen. Ich hab tatsächlich, das fand ich auch ganz interessant, es gibt nämlich bei diesen dynamischen DNS-Diensten, die kann man auch im Netz sich buchen, für ab und zu sogar mehrere Euro im Monat. Wenn man aber eh schon bei einem Web-Hoster ist zum Beispiel, die bieten das manchmal mit an. Also meiner zum Beispiel macht das, da kann man so sagen, dass ich so eine Sache mit anbieten.
Die traurige Wahrheit ist, das ist auch überhaupt kein Aufwand. Das ist wie so was wie Microsense, die du dort dann investieren musst. Wenn du mal irgendeinen Rechner im Netz stehen hast, dann ist dort das, was an dem Datenverkehr da passiert und was du dann an Fragen beantworten musst, das einfach so zu vernachlässigen. Das heißt, da überhaupt Geld für zu nehmen, ist schon...
Aber wenn es geht, dann können wir sie auch ausnehmen.
Es ist ein gutes Cashcoding, weil es halt einfach so... Also wenn man sich halt damit auseinandersetzt, ist es relativ einfach. Aber soweit muss es halt erstmal kommen. Und deswegen sagt dann so eine Firma so, ja, ich mach dir jetzt für zwei Euro im Monat. Dass die da halt einmal 100 Euro investiert haben, weil das jemand eine Stunde aufsetzt. Und dann kommen halt die Leute und zahlen immer zwei Euro im Monat.
Und lustigerweise, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, ist dünnDNS, also der bekannteste Anbieter, wo diese Name eigentlich herkommt, bietet nicht mehr kostenlos dünnDNS an.
Du musst glaube ich alle 15 Tage jetzt eine Mail klicken. Also es ist kostenlos und dafür richtig, richtig nervig geworden.
Aber wenn wir schon dabei sind, jetzt von wieder zentralisierten Services zu sprechen, weil dünnDNS ist ja dann nicht mehr von dir selber betrieben, dann kannst du auch gleich dir von einem dieser Anbieter so einen VPN Endpunkt irgendwo besorgen. Sowas wie die Leute, die da Pirate Bay betrieben haben, die verdicken sowas. Oder es gibt andere Firmen, die auch sagen, da mach einfach ein virtuelles Netzwerk, da kommst du dann irgendwo raus, wo vielleicht auch YouTube deutlich besser zu klicken ist und kannst dann einfach ein virtuelles Netzwerk an irgendeinen Server nach Schweden oder einen Server in die Schweiz anlegen und hast dann da auch immer dieselbe IP-Adresse. Das heißt, dass dein gesamtes Zuhause-Netzwerk dann plötzlich nicht mehr in Deutschland ins Internet fällt, sondern irgendwo anders, aber mit einer festen IP-Adresse, die du dann auch einfach rausgeben kannst.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Welchen Punkt? Also wir hatten gerade den Punkt, dass bei mir zu Hause ein Rechner steht und dass der sozusagen, weil mein Internetanschluss alle 24 Stunden getrennt wird, jedes Mal eine neue Hausnummer bekommt.
Jetzt stell dir vor, du hast von zu Hause auf deinem Router ein Stück Software, dem ist total egal, welche IP-Adresse er da gerade bei seinem Anbieter bekommt. Er baut immer eine Verbindung und irgendein Rechenzentrum auf, wo er eine feste IP-Adresse bekommt, wo die Daten dann einfach durch einen verschlüsselten Tunnel, durch das Internet, egal was da gerade der Weg ist.
Also stell dir vor, du hast einen Wohnwagen, der einfach immer ungepackt wird, aber du hast einen Tunnel davor, der immer in der Schweiz an der Müller Straße 42 rauskommt, egal wo du deinen Wohnwagen parkst.
Und wenn ich nach Hause will, fahre ich immer zur Müller Straße 42 in der Schweiz und dann von da automatisch...
Dann wird das Paket ein bisschen neu verpackt und wird zu dir, wo auch immer du gerade heute bist, hingedrückt.
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden. So, und der Jan hat angerufen. Aus Charlottenburg. Hallo Jan. Der will nämlich auch was zu diesen DNS-Diensten sagen. Hallo Jan.
Ja, hi. Und zwar zweierlei. Einmal böser Fallstrick, wo man echt verzweifeln dran kann. Ihr kennt ja die lustigen Speedports von der Telekom.
Nee, was ist das?
Speedport ist halt einfach so ein Router.
Ach so, auch so ein Router, ok.
Genau. Und die haben natürlich auch so einen dünnen DNS-Eintrag drin. Der ist aber ziemlich hinterlistig. Wenn man zuhause seinen Server damit betreibt. Ich hab's gehabt mit einem Kalender- und Kontakt-Server. Der löst von außen auf, also das heißt nicht aus dem Internet, mit einem Mobiltelefon den Server zuhause erreichen will, löst der ganz problemlos auf, alles schick. Und dann standen wir da und wollten vom Internet übers Mehl an einfach nur die Kontakte und die Kalender und Ländereinträge aktualisieren und das Ding hat nicht synchronisiert und es gab immer nur Fehlermeldungen, der Server sei nicht erreichbar. Und diese Speedboards lösen intern nicht auf die Domänen.
Also der kennt sich von intern nicht, nur wenn man von außen fragt, weiß er wer er ist.
Genau.
Klingt ja total bescheuert.
Aber ich würde auch sagen, also ich würde anfangen, wenn man tatsächlich ein Speedboard hat, ich würde mir wirklich überlegen, ob ich nicht einen anderen Router erst mal erklärt habe.
Da gibt es immer eine technische Erklärung, allerdings weiß ich, woran es liegt, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht für das Radio.
Vielleicht trefft er euch nachher nochmal zum Bier.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, kannst du auch gerne noch eine Meldung an Chaosradio at ccc.de schreiben.
Ja, also der Hintergrund täte mich wirklich interessieren, weil ich bin nicht drauf gekommen.
Also beschreib mir gerne die Mail, ich kann es dir gerne erklären, aber das ist so jenseits von einfach zu erklären.
Das würde möglicherweise ein bisschen nach Mitternacht lauten. So viel Zeit haben wir nicht. Also Jan, schreibst du eine Mail?
Ja, das mach ich. Aber ich wollte noch für das Dünn DNS, um sich seine eigene Domain, also richtig so die eigene ich.de nach Hause zu leiten, gibt es noch einen hübschen Dienst von FreeDNS. Unter afraid.org, also afraid.org gibt es einen FreeDNS Service. Da kann ich mit meinen eigenen Domänen, die ich bei meinem Domain-Host da irgendwo mir gemietet oder gekauft habe, kann ich da einfach auf eine x-beliebige Domain auch einen Dünn-DNS legen.
Das bieten inzwischen ganz schön viele an, weil im Prinzip ist das rein sehr einfach. Du musst halt einfach deiner Kiste zu Hause sagen, dass sie immer nur irgendeine Webseite aufruft, zum Beispiel, reicht da aus. Und da ist halt also ich kenne inzwischen echt eine ganze Packung an Domain-Anbietern oder Hurricane Electric zum Beispiel, dns.he.net, die bieten das so von Haus aus an, da sagst du einfach hier, rufst du einmal am Tag mit deinem Webbrowser diese URL auf und dann passt die IP wieder und weißt immer, wo dein Webbrowser gerade ist.
Falls ihr gerade irgendwie vorm Radio sitzt und hektisch irgendwie Notizzettel mitschreibt und die ganzen Namen irgendwie. Es gibt ein Projekt, das heißt Show Notes, ist glaube ich auch unter shownote.es zu erreichen und die sitzen tatsächlich, die machen diesen Job, die sitzen vorm Radio, schreiben alles mit, was hier passiert und dann kann man das hinterher nachschlagen. Also vielen Dank erstmal dafür. Das ist so ein Community Service, das heißt, für Leute, die das auch Spaß und Freude machen. Und da könnt ihr das alles nachschlagen. Jan, letzte Frage noch an dich. Du hast ja gesagt, dass du Kalender und Kontakt-Synchronisationen darüber versucht hast. Was hast du dazu benutzt?
Ich habe mir den CalDAV Server, also Kalender und Kontext Server von Apple genommen. Der ist open source, desquelloffen. Und habe den auf dem Mac Mini kompiliert.
Okay, also du hast, also das okay, ich hatte gehofft, du sagst jetzt sowas. Ja, ich habe aus dem Internet diese Software genommen und habe sie einfach installiert und das war total super.
Ich habe es mit Davy Carl probiert, aber die haben irgendwie damals, als ich probiert habe, noch nicht so richtig schön mit iPhone und Co zusammengearbeitet.
Aber man hätte auch einfach macOS 10 Server nehmen können.
Hätte man auch, aber das kostet, als ich es probiert habe damals, das war noch unter 10, 6er Zeit, da kostete das echt noch, ich glaube, 500 Euro oder so.
Und es werden schon noch an Flöten gegangen, wo man einfach da sitzt und Dinge kompiliert bei einem Bier.
Auch nicht nur einer.
Nochmal jetzt noch eine Frage. Die klassischen Betriebssysteme als Server, also Windows und OS X, gibt es sowas? Ist das teuer?
Windows als Server?
Ich möchte nur wissen, ob es das gibt und ob das kostet.
Also ich glaube Exchange Server kostet noch, aber dieser Mac OS Server, der kostet inzwischen einen Zehner im App Store.
Das ist gerade Mac OS. Mac OS oder? Nein, der Mac OS Server, aber du kannst auch den Windows Server, soweit ich weiß, kostenlos für eigene Bedarf mittlerweile. Also man kann da eine ISO umsonst bei Microsoft runterladen, wenn man...
Oder man macht das Ganze mit Open Source und holt sich halt sein Image von Raspberry Pi. Also es gibt diverse Möglichkeiten, die wahrscheinlich alles gleiche tun am Ende.
Nee genau, aber im App Store ist das so, wenn ich weiß, so 10 Euro für den aktuellen...
Also die Preise sind halt massiv runtergegangen in den letzten Jahren.
Also mal abgesehen davon, dass natürlich, ich mir möglicherweise sagen würde, nein, ich soll ja nicht relativieren, sagt die Open-Source-Förderung ist immer die bessere. Aber so dieses OS-10-Server, Windows-Server, ich meine, das ist halt schön bunt und man kann das angucken.
Also Windows-Server würde ich aber nicht empfehlen.
Dann nimmst du die gleich Plesk. Also das gibt es ja auch für Linux. Es gibt auch eine Administrationsoberfläche, die sieht inzwischen glaube ich genauso schick aus, wie die von Apple Server als Plesk für Linux. Und dann klickst du da drauf, kannst dir deine Services anklicken, haben sich auch Leute Gedanken gemacht. Und dann kannst du sagen, dieser Service, dieser Service, dieser Service, fertig. Und das gibt es, wenn du dir so Linux-Hoster nimmst, dann ist das auch schon vorinstalliert. Da musst du auch nicht wirklich Closed Source nehmen.
Aber das ist dann nicht mehr zu Hause, Erdgeist.
Plesk kannst du dir auch zu Hause installieren, erzähl doch.
Doch.
Warte, keine insider Gags reißen die Leute ohne dich verwirrend. Dieses Plesk, kann man das zu Hause installieren oder nicht?
Ich glaube, nee, das gibt es schon viel zu Hause, aber das würde ich, also das, wo man Plesk eigentlich kennt, ist das, wenn man bei seinem großen Anbieter geht, dann ist das fast immer umsonst dabei. Also das ist schon ein Mehraufwand.
Also es gibt halt auch Verlienungen zwischen den Komfort von einer bunten Oberfläche mit runden Ecken, wie man es von Mac OS oder von Windows oder Windows, nee Windows hat eckige Ecken, aber es gibt eine Green.
Man, Leute, es war eine einfache Frage und ihr macht es kompliziert. Also es gibt diese Software und man kann sie sozusagen bedienen und sie ist wahrscheinlich sozusagen von der Rechenleistung nicht das Effizienteste, aber sie ist schon bunt.
Brauchst du mich jetzt, wenn ich OnCloud vorschlage, weil genau das ist das eigentlich so.
Nein, nein, mach ich natürlich nicht.
Reinstecken und dann tut das einfach. Du kannst dir klicken und sagst mein Account, mein Kalender und das schert alles.
Aber du musst ja fragen, warum jemand überhaupt OS X oder Microsoft zu Hause haben will.
Weil du eine alte Rechner rumstehen hast. Also wenn du einen Mac Mini wie du hast, dann spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen, da einfach einen OS X Server da drauf zu installieren.
Na, man könnte ja natürlich auch ein schönes Linux drauf installieren. Der Rechner ist einfach nur schön stromsparend. Also der nimmt ja auch nicht maxi viel mehr als so ein Raspberry Pi.
Ich würde sagen, das ist so...
Nee. Also maximal 5 Watt.
Also an dieser Stelle möchte ich das Gespräch abrechnen und bitte euch in dem Arbeitskreis Stromausrechnen Community zu treffen und das mal so sagen genau auszufechten. Es geht mir jetzt tatsächlich nur darum zu sagen, liebe Leute, wenn ihr Angst davon habt, weil ihr glaubt, das ist alles nur mit Kommandozahlen und ganz fürchtlich kompensiert und müsst selber Dinge kompilieren. Nein, ihr könnt auch einfach bunte Sachen runterladen, die man klicken kann. Und ganz ehrlich, ich mach das auch. Und OwnCloud ist zum Beispiel ein Beispiel, in der Abübrüche sprechen wir gleich. Jan, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank auch und schöne Sendung noch.
So, schöne Sendung hat er gesagt und wir müssen gleich mal erklären, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Fertig. Oh oh Herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio auf fritz.de im Blue Moon und jetzt mit den Nerd-Nachrichten.
Route updaten. Nach dem Medienrummel um eine Schwachstelle in verschiedenen Fritzbox-Modellen des Herstellers AVM haben auch Cisco, Netgear und Linksys nach langem Warten Schwachstellen in ihren Geräten behoben. Da diese jedoch zumeist nicht automatisch aufgespielt werden, sollten sich Besitzer auf der Website des Herstellers über Updates für ihre Route informieren. Office User in Gefahr. Eine ungepatchte Lücke in Microsoft Office Produkten ermöglicht es Angreifern, Rechnern mit einer speziell gestalteten Formatierungsanweisung in Dokumenten zu übernehmen. Da Outlook diese Formatierung automatisch anzeigt, kann dies bereits über die Forscherfunktion geschehen, wie das Security-Blogger Brian Krebs meldete. Damit lassen sich Rechner auch dann infizieren, wenn der Benutzer die Mail eigentlich nur löschen will. Microsoft hat die Lücke bislang nur für Word bestätigt. Betroffen sind sowohl Windows als auch Mac OS. Sicherheitshalber sollten Benutzer das Anzeigen von HTML-Mails und die automatische Vorschau von Outlook deaktivieren. Intelligente Stromzähler auf Malta manipuliert. Durch Manipulation von sogenannten Smartmetern hat eine Betrügerbande im Jahr 2012 Strom im Wert von 30 Millionen Euro gestohlen. Die Bande, zu der auch korrupte Mitarbeiter des Energieversorgers Ene Malta zählten, hatte die Software der Zähler so verändert, dass sie bei einigen Leuten bis zu 75 Prozent weniger Verbrauch anzeigten. Um den Betrug zu vertuschen, wurden offenbar auch anderen Ortszähler ahnungsloser Stromkunden manipuliert, damit die Gesamtbilanz wieder stimmte. Der Diebstahl blieb daher lange unerkannt. Neues Leben für Full Disclosure. Die Mailing-Liste, auf den Sicherheitsforscher gefundene Sicherheitslücken in Software zeitnah veröffentlicht hatten, hat nach zwölf Jahren die ihre Tore geschlossen. Als Grund nannte John Cartwright, der bisherige Administrator der Liste, Forderungen, großflächig Inhalte aus der Liste zu löschen. Nmap-Erfinder Fyodor Vaskovic hauchte der Liste nun neues Leben ein. Er betreibt mit zeklis.org bereits eine ganze Reihe ähnlicher Mailing-Listen. Das waren die Nerd-Nachrichten im Chaosradio auf Fritz.
Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da.
Ich bin schon mal da. Bertie Cox mit Utopia hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz, wo Leute vom Chaos Computer Club zu Gast sind, um heute über Eigenhosting zu sprechen. Das sind zum Beispiel der Erdgeist, der Kai und der Dmitry. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Und wir sprechen heute darüber, wie man es schaffen kann, dass man sich selbst darum kümmert, dass die Dienste, die man sonst normalerweise nur im Internet benutzt, dass man die zu Hause macht. Wir haben schon geklärt, warum man das machen sollte. Bastelspaß ist nicht eine unwesentliche Motivation. Wir haben schon geklärt, dass es zumindest für den Anfang sinnvoller ist, wenn man zu Hause mit einer kleinen Rechenmaschine unter dem eigenen Schreibtisch arbeitet. Und wir haben auch geklärt, wie man die dann überhaupt dazu kriegt, dass die mit dem Internet sprechen kann. All das in der ersten Stunde dieser Sendung, die ihr auch im Nachhinein als Podcast hören könnt auf fritz.de oder chaosradio.ccc.de. So, wir haben also jetzt schon einen Computer, der hängt auch im Internet und da muss jetzt Software drauf. Und wir haben jetzt schon so ein bisschen drüber gehalten und es fiel immer wieder der Name. Also gerade wenn es so um die typischen Cloud-Sachen geht, die man so haben will. Also Dateien synchronisieren, Kalender und Kontakte, dass man da zum Beispiel, Kai hat gesagt, ich würde ihn vielleicht schlagen, wenn ich das sagen würde, ich weiß gar nicht, warum er das getan hat, OwnCloud. Das ist eine so eine Software, die kann man halt relativ simpel, also relativ, ich habe mal versucht, eine Anleitung dafür zu schreiben, die ist glaube ich fünf oder sechs Seiten lang, auf einen Rechner drauf spielen. Aber es geht ohne Vorahnung, ohne Vorwissen, mit ein wenig Ahnung so rum, habe ich schon mal probiert. So, aber jetzt erklärt doch mal, was dieses OwnCloud eigentlich ist, was es kann und was es nicht kann.
Ich wollte dir eigentlich nur nicht vorweggreifen, dem Thema, wie ich schon am Anfang tat. Aber das OwnCloud ist eigentlich eine Lösung, die macht so Dropbox und Google Kalender und Google Kontakte und Foto-Flicker-Sharing, alles zum Selbst-Zuhause-Hosten. Und du hast, glaube ich, schon ein Auto erzählt, du hast das benutzt und das halt wirklich auch so in so einer kurzen Fünf-Schritt-Anleitung so downloaden, auf eine SD-Karte packen, in den Raspberry stecken und schon läuft's. So für die eigene Anwendung und je nachdem wie groß und wie viel man das braucht, kann man das halt auch richtig selbst installieren, auf den Server in Datacenter packen. Und dann ist das natürlich viel größer, hat viel mehr Kraft als ein kleiner Raspberry Pi. Aber das macht halt eigentlich so alles, was man eigentlich braucht, um so von der Cloud ein bisschen wegzukommen.
Also das ist tatsächlich dann die Own Cloud, könnte man sagen, also wie das ja auch sozusagen heißt.
Für mich ist der Begriff Cloud ja immer so negativ besetzt, dass es mir immer schwer fällt, irgendwie um das ins Herz zu legen.
Aber es sagt ja auch Own Cloud, so ist halt die eigene Cloud.
Es ist ja sozusagen, es ist ja dieses, das ist für dich glaube ich nur negativ belegt. Also weil tatsächlich, weil du wahrscheinlich damit verbindest, sozusagen das sind dann auch gleich die großen Anbieter, dabei das Konzept.
Nein, Cloud ist ursprünglich, als die Netzwerkingenieure so Diagramme gezeichnet haben. Das kann dauern, Leute. Da war die Cloud immer genau das unsichere Internetwolke. Genau, die Internetwolke, wo einfach, man weiß nicht, da kommen eventuell, wenn man Glück hat, Daten durch. Aber dem hat man, denen kann man nicht vertrauen. Und man muss dafür sorgen, dass es eventuell noch Alternativen gibt drum rum. Irgendwie passiert da drin irgendwas und dann kommt auf der anderen Seite was an. Die Netzwerkingenieure haben dem immer schon so ziemlich nase rümpfend, sind dem begegnet. Und da jetzt zu sagen, genau da soll meine Daten hin, sollte jedem, dem was an seinen Daten liegt, sollte einfach, nein, die stopft man nicht einfach so in diese Cloud, dieses unsichere Ding, sondern...
Na du weißt halt am Ende nicht, wo die Daten liegen, sondern du siehst nur irgendwie eine Webseite. Und ob das dann bei den Amis oder in deutscher Restriktion, oder ob das öffentlich oder ganz sicher gelagert ist, ob das tausende von Sicherheitslücken hat oder nicht, das weiß man halt einfach nicht.
Apropos tausende Sicherheitslücken, kommen wir zurück zur Umgangsklänge.
Jetzt kommst du mit den Insider-Witzen.
Ja, also einer, verstehe, einer sei mir nochmal geduldet. Nein, wir haben jetzt schon festgestellt, das kann halt so einiges und der Name Cloud bedeutet eigentlich was anderes, aber Sprache lebt, es ändert sich, also es geht darum, dass sie uns sozusagen den Service, den man online nutzen kann, auf dem eigenen Rechner anbietet. Die haben tatsächlich auch in einer letzten Version sogar so eine Art Google Docs-Ersatz da, also gibt es so ein Plugin, was man da benutzen kann. Das ist noch alles sehr wackelig, habe ich das Gefühl, aber es ist auf dem Weg dahin. Trotzdem, oder andersrum, Kai, du benutzt das?
Nee, ich bin ehrlich gesagt ganz schlecht hier, weil ich hier überhaupt zu Hause gar nichts hoste, außer meine Mails und mein IRC und mehr betreibe ich nicht privat. Aber ich betreibe es für andere Leute öfters. Aber ich kenne es halt tatsächlich, die hingehen und die kennen halt den Komfort von dropbox.com oder von Gmail und sagen dann, ja, aber ich will jetzt Rechtsklick machen und das dann meinen Freunden schicken mit den Fotos vom Wochenenden. Und dann sitzt halt immer da, ja, wie machst du das jetzt? Erklärst du ihnen, wie sie irgendwie Gallery und PAP aufsetzen? Oder ach nee, Moment, inzwischen gibt es halt OwnCloud, wo das halt alles echt einfach ist. Du sagst einfach hier Rechtsklick, Share und fertig. Und das ist halt, das ist halt endlich mal eine Eigenlösung, die halt an den Komfort rankommt von damit, wo die Großen mit Geld machen, die halt in der Cloud liegen tatsächlich.
So, trotzdem, wenn man diesen Namen sagt und sich in den Highbrow Nerd-Crisen bewegt, kommt dann auch so ein Augenbrauen hochziehen und Naso rümpfen manchmal. Also das ist so, OwnCloud ist nicht dabei, es hat jetzt der Schluss anscheinend. Das Vorteil ist, man kann es relativ einfach installieren und es kann relativ viel. Was sind die Nachteile?
Sicherheitslücken.
Das ist in PHP geschrieben und...
Erklärt, erklärt. Also, verstehst du, wenn du jetzt sagst, das ist in PHP geschrieben...
Ich hatte schon noch ein und hinterhergeschrieben. Und diese Programmiersprache ist eigentlich eine wandelnde Sicherheitslücke. Diese Programmiersprache wurde nicht entwickelt, sondern sie hat sich von selber entwickelt. Irgendwie jeder, der mal ein Feature brauchte, hat da ein bisschen was herangeklatscht. Und inzwischen ist es so unintuitiv, dass selbst die besten Programmierer, die dort in PHP unterwegs sind, es nicht schaffen, dort wirklich sichere Software zu stricken. Und ist einfach ganz...
Also das beste Beispiel für mich ist immer bei OwnCloud, dass man... Also das ist wirklich... Man muss wirklich dazu sagen, das ist die aller einfachste Lösung, die ich jemals gesehen habe, die so eine Lösung für alles und alles funktioniert. Aber es gibt so Beispiele an Sachen, von Sachen, die in OwnCloud in PHP nachimplementiert sind, wie die komplette WebDAF, sozusagen dieses Protokoll, ist komplett in PHP geschrieben. Obwohl jeder Web Server, also man braucht, man muss das so sagen, OwnCloud ist eigentlich eine Web Anwendung. Also das läuft auf einem Web Server. Und diese Web Server unterstützen alle von sich aus auch WebDAF. Also aber man aus welchem Grund auch immer, wahrscheinlich weil man sich nicht drauf verlassen konnte, was die Web Server in verschiedenen Konfigurationen können und nicht, hat man sich entschieden, bei OwnCloud ein wesentlicher Teil des ganzen Servers in PHP nachzuschreiben. Und laute solche Entscheidungen führen eigentlich zur angreifbaren Code, also der nicht besonders sicher ist.
Ah, da sag ich, würde ich jetzt so als Argument eigentlich bringen, so du kannst das halt bei dir zu Hause laufen lassen, wo keiner hinkommt. Und außerdem, wenn ich mir, also um wieder auf das Beispiel Dropbox zu kommen, ich hab mir da mal einen Account angelegt für ein Projekt auf der Arbeit, wo ich das brauchte. Und inzwischen kriege ich da Spam auf die Mailadresse und ich benutze halt pro Dienst eine eigene Mailadresse und denk mir halt so, hm, woher kommt denn der Spam? Und ist da nur meine Mailadresse abhandengekommen oder sind da auch die Daten abhandengekommen? Und da sag ich mir so, okay, bei OnCloud kann ich immerhin dann selbst den Stecker ziehen, wenn es mir zu heikel wird, während bei den Cloud-Diensten, da regnet es dann halt einfach mal Daten irgendwo raus und du bist halt richtig machtlos.
Na, das ist jetzt mal so eine spannende Frage, die, wenn ich jetzt meinen eigenen kleinen Rechner betreibe und da diese OnCloud irgendwie draufhabe und die hat jetzt mal theoretisch eine Sicherheitslücke angenommen, aber außer mir benutzt diesen Rechner eigentlich gar nicht. Kann die dann trotzdem rausgefunden werden? Also nicht die Sicherheitslücke, sondern kann da jemand meinen Rechner konkret anwenden?
Da gehen doch jeden Tag, wenn man irgendeine IP-Adresse hat, die am Internet sich befindet, da gehen bei mir auf dem Server pro Minute zehn Verbindungsversuche von überall auf der Welt ein, die einfach mal am Türknopf rütteln, um zu gucken, ob es aufgeht. Das ist so wie die kleinen Panker, die über die Straße runterlaufen, an die eben auch mal gucken, ob die Tür aufgeht, und wenn, dann freuen sie sich rein. Und heutzutage das gesamte Internet, alle IP-Adressen aus dem IPv4-Bereich da abzuklappern, geht, wenn du eine fette Leitung hast, die du dir von irgendeinem, ja, als Zombie übernommenen Rechner entwickelst. Ja, oder vom Kongress aus, da bist du in unternem Tag durch alle Rechner durch, und wenn du da nicht hier viel Daten hinschicken musst, weil, wenn dann ganz einfache Anfrage an den Webserver ausreicht, um den Dienst aufzumachen und zu übernehmen, dann, ja, musst du damit rechnen. Wenn du eine Adresse hast, die aus dem Internet erreichbar ist, dann kommt irgendwann auch mal jemand vorbei und rüttelt an deiner Tür. Und dann, schwupps, macht der im besten Fall, benutzt er dich einfach und übernimmt deinen Rechner und macht daraus einen Zombie, um Spam zu verschicken oder...
Das ist also auch nicht ganz ungefährlich, so einen eigenen zu betreiben, oder ist das nur bei OnCloud so?
Das ist eigentlich bei allem, was im Internet so, egal ob selbst geschrieben, ob fertig installiert, ob Open- oder Closed-Source, du hast überall Security-Lücken, ist halt einfach so das Risiko. Und bei den bekannten Anwendungen, die jeder nutzt, gibt es das halt so von der Stange zum Aufmachen. Und wenn es halt selten ist, muss man halt ein bisschen Arbeit rein investieren, aber kriegt die Anwendung trotzdem auf.
Genau, das ist einfach so ein bisschen wie im Straßenverkehr. Du hast da ein allgemeines Lebensrisiko und im Zweifel hast du Backups. Wenn dir jemand den Rechner aufmacht, dann spielst du die Backups wieder ein und dann hoffst du, dass der Anbieter der Software irgendwann mal ein Update einspielt, dass dein Service zu Hause nicht alle Minuten übernommen wird.
Und wenn es ganz wichtig ist, dann gehst du einfach nicht in den Straßenverkehr bzw. stellst die Dokumente einfach nicht ins Internet, sondern lagerst sie auf einer Platte zu Hause. Das ist halt so, muss man halt abwägen, was dann halt wirklich, ja...
Wenn die NSA hinter dir her ist, dann würdest du dir auch in den Arsch treten. Wenn du deine Software nicht pflegst, die du installiert hast auf deinem eigenen Server, der über das Internet zu erreichen ist, dann musst du auch damit rechnen, dass jemand alte und bekannte Sicherheitslücken ausnutzt und wie wir eben in den Nerd-Nachrichten gelernt haben, ist auch eine Firma wie AVM, die die Fritz-Boxen herstellt oder Cisco, nicht davor gefeiert, in den Routern, die ja per Definition dort in großem Stil am Internet angeschlossen sind und in 100.000-fach sogar, dass die, naja, nicht Hintertüchen, sondern Sicherheitslücken aufweisen, mit denen dann der Rechner übernommen werden kann.
Ist Augenteuer jetzt sozusagen die einzige Software, die sowas macht oder gibt es da auch noch Alternativen, also im Sinne von, die muss ich mir nicht sehr zusammen kompensieren, programmieren, was auch immer?
Es gibt diverse Alternativen. Es gibt ein arcos.io, auch ein Projekt, was wie sehr slick aussieht und sich dann nochmal auf den Anfangsanwender richtet. Die machen dann nochmal den genanen Extra Schritt mehr, dass es gebügelt und schick aussieht. Und ich werde da bestimmt jetzt einigen Projekten nicht gerecht, die ich jetzt auch kennen sollte.
Aber zum Beispiel ein sehr beliebter, der vielleicht noch erwähnenswert ist, weil er eben im Gegensatz zu OwnCloud doch sehr viel weniger Code ist und weniger massiv ist. Das ist Devica oder ich glaube, das heißt, ich vergesse immer, doch Devica ist der aktuelle Name. Die hatten irgendeinen anderen Namen davor, aber das kann ich empfehlen. Das Problem ist eigentlich, wenn man sich mit dieser ganzen Thematik beschäftigt, was man sehr oft sieht, ist zum Beispiel, es kommt ein iOS 8 raus, also meistens ist das eine große Version und plötzlich funktioniert nichts mehr. Und wenn man auf diese Daten, wenn man sie braucht, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass man erst mal einen Monat warten muss, bis der nächste Update kommt, bis es wieder funktioniert. Und bei OwnCloud, muss man dazu sagen, sie bemühen sich sehr, um möglichst mit allen populären Geräten kompetibel zu sein. Und beispielsweise bei DeviCal kenne ich das auch von den Medienlisten dort. Der Entwickler da schreibt sehr oft, na, es funktioniert nicht mit Apple, aber das ist nicht mein Problem, denn Apple hat sich nicht an den Standard gehalten.
Genau das andere Ende ist ein Projekt, das heißt ReadyCale, und das ist ein klitzekleines, in Python geschriebenes Skript, was als Mission Statement geschrieben hat, wir sind faul, wir sind stinkend faul. Wir wissen, dieser Standard ist mehrere hundert Seiten lang. Wir haben da keine Lust, den komplett durchzuimplementieren. Wir haben einfach mal alles implementiert, was man braucht, um mit einem iOS, mit einem MacOS, mit dem Android-Telefon und mit dem Windows sprechen zu können und hier ist das Skript, und du kannst es benutzen und das einfach aufzusetzen. Und das macht dir Kontakte und Kalender sinken. Und das tut es sehr schnell, klein und gut. Und es ist dann so das andere Ende des Spektrums, wo die sich dann nicht hinsetzen und sagen, ja, ist nicht unsere Schuld, sondern die gucken, welche Features gebraucht werden und implementieren genau die.
Es gibt also genug Auswahl und es gibt eigentlich nichts mehr, was euch abhalten sollte, das auszuprobieren. Also insbesondere, solange wir nur von Synchronisationsdiensten reden, also die eure Kalender, eure Kontakte oder eure Dateiordner replizieren, also von eurem Rechner auf diesen online Rechner noch übertragen, ist das Backup ja quasi automatisch mitgemacht, weil alle Daten sich ja zu jedem beliebigen Zeitpunkt immer auf mehreren Rechnern befinden. Also auf allen euren Rechnern und dieser kleinen Box, die irgendwo zu Hause stehen hat.
Naja, das ist ja kein Backup, weil wenn du es dann auf deinem Laptop löscht, ist es auch gleich zu Hause gelöscht.
Also wenn du nicht noch regelmäßig Snapshots dann auf deinem Server nimmst, dann wird auch ein gelöschter Kontakt auch synchronisiert. Alles mach mal weg.
Okay, dann müssen wir nochmal unterscheiden. Zwei Arten von Backups. Das eine Backup dient ja dazu zu sagen, der eigene kleine Rechner zu Hause oder irgendwas schmiert irgendwo ab, also so raucht komplett ab. Dann hat man es natürlich die Daten auf einer anderen Maschine. Dieses, ich habe etwas gelöscht und will es eigentlich nochmal wieder haben. Das ist natürlich richtig. Gibt es denn da einfache Lösungen, um sozusagen dem eigenen kleinen Rechner beizubringen, hier nochmal alle Daten irgendwie?
Es geht auf das Betriebssystem an. Mein Lieblingsbetriebssystem FreeBSD bietet mit dem jetzt da mal mitgelieferten Filesystem namens ZFS so ziemlich billig an, keine Ahnung, im Halbstundentakt zu Snapshotten. Und also spricht den aktuellen Stand des gesamten Betriebssystems mit all den Daten einfach jetzt mal zu freezen und zu jedem beliebigen späteren Zeitpunkt wieder zu sagen, roll mal kurz zurück. Und man kann diese Snapshots dann auch überall noch zum anderen Backup-Server hinschicken. Bin ich halt in meiner Administratoren-Säle da irgendwie auch verliebt in dieses Feature und benutze es überall, wo es nur geht. Aber ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich gibt es in Linux eine ähnliche Option.
Auf Linux macht es dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie Googles nach Ubuntu und Backup und findet 20 Lösungen mit verschiedensten GUI, nicht GUI und Abarten. Also da gibt es halt das Spektrum von tuteinfach bis hin hat 10.000 Stellrädchen. Und ich persönlich bin halt so auf dem Desktop richtig faul und will einfach das tut und hab halt meinen Share und da geht halt dieses Time Machine drauf und speichert einfach. Während auch bei uns auf Arbeit ist das halt ein bisschen komplexer. Da kommt halt wirklich einmal am Tag der Service, nimmt alles auseinander und speichert alles, was sich geändert hat, weg. Aber nicht das, was am Tag davor war und also so einfach Backup. Pro System relativ viele Optionen, wie man es am Ende löst, ist dann glaube ich so eine persönliche Geschmackssache.
Also ich habe im Prinzip das gleiche wie die anderen beiden Jungs hier. Ich habe einen Backup Server zu Hause und mache ZFS Snapshots und Time Machine und alle diese Dinge. Also irgendwann, wenn man genug Ahnung für diesen ganzen Kram hat, dann will man sich doch eine fette Kiste zu Hause irgendwie hinstellen.
Apropos fette Kiste, das würde mich gleich mal interessieren, weil möglicherweise hat sich jetzt jemand das Chaosradio angehört und denkt, es ist so geile Sache, das probiere ich aus. Und fängt das an zu basteln, stellt dann fest, das funktioniert sogar irgendwie. Erzählt dann voller Begeisterung seinen Freunden davon, das ist voll super und es funktioniert. Und ich bin nicht mehr bei Dropbox, sondern bin jetzt sozusagen nur noch mein eigener Admin. Und dann sagen seine Freunde, das ist total geil, dass du das gemacht hast, dass ich mal persönlich das nicht machen möchte, aber kannst du mir nicht einen Account bei dir anlegen? Würdet ihr das empfehlen? Oder sagt ihr eher so, naja...
So fing das bei mir ja an. Ich hab auch irgendwann mal dann angefangen, das dann auch da halb zu, naja, nicht professionalisieren, aber mit einem professionellen Anspruch daherzugehen und dieses Anbieten von Services und dieses Wegseparieren von Diensten, dass sie sich nicht gegenseitig ins Gehege bekommen. Und dann, weil so einen Server im Internet zu mieten, war damals noch so ein richtiges Kostending. Heute kriegt man so einen virtuellen Server für 5 Dollar im Monat. Damals musste es da schon noch mindestens, naja, war es da so mit, da war es noch D-Mark-Preise, ne, da war es so mit 70, 80 D-Mark mindestens dabei. Und dann hab ich dann gesagt, dass ich mir das gerne teilen würde mit Freunden. Und dann haben wir dann angefangen, so allen Accounts zu geben. Und jeder hat sein Mailserver aufgesetzt da drauf und seine eigene E-Mail betrieben. Und jeder hat dann wieder seine Nameserver gemacht. Und dann fingen noch Leute an, Filesharing zu machen. Dann musste man dann irgendwann mal anfangen, das da so zu konsolidieren, dafür zu sorgen, dass nicht jeder in jede andere Software reinfuscht. Und ja, bei der Gelegenheit hab ich ihm gesagt, gut, dann mach ich irgendwie mal einen Mailserver, wo ich den administriere. Und alle anderen können dann ihre Mails damit reinziehen. Und dann fingen das so an. Und dann, wenn du schon mal sowas installiert hast, dann kommt jemand anders daher und sagt, ah, es ist mir grad so viel Ärger und so viele Sicherheitslücken. Kann ich meine Mails nicht auch bei dir? Und dann kommst du dann irgendwann in so... Dann bist du plötzlich so auch Internet-Service Provider. Dann bist du plötzlich auch so... Irgendwann kommen dann auch... Du musst aufpassen, dass nicht da zu viele Benutzer bei dir die Mail-Mittel liegen haben. Und dann musst du plötzlich aufpassen, dass wenn die Leute dann versuchen, ihre Mails rauszuschicken, dann geht's irgendwann nicht, weil jemand behauptet, du würdest von einem Rechner aus Spam verschicken.
Bist du dann auch bei der Bnetz A angemeldet? Da muss man ja auch Mailserver inzwischen anmelden, glaube ich.
Bitte was?
Ich glaube, bei der Bundesnetzagentur muss man heutzutage in Deutschland, wenn man einen Mailserver für Dritte betreibt, den anmelden.
Also auch, wenn ich meinen eigenen kleinen Mailserver betreibe?
Das ist, glaube ich, so Auslegungssache. Ich weiß nicht, ob das kommerziell ist, aber auf jeden Fall, man muss es jetzt anmelden, wie so auch immer. Aber ich sehe halt bei der ganzen Sache, mit Dienste für Freunde betreiben, das macht halt Spaß. Nur man muss halt wissen, worauf man sich einlässt. Also du stellst halt einen Dienst für deine Freunde und Familie oder so bereit. Und die denken dann einfach, du machst das schon, das läuft immer. Und wenn du halt in zwei Jahren keinen Bock hast, musst du ja halt auch damit denken. Du musst halt schon sehen, das betreibe ich halt, ich kümmere mich. Vor allem habe ich dann die Daten von anderen Menschen, um die ich mich da kümmere. Und das ist dann schon eine Verantwortung, die man da hat. Also das ist jetzt nichts, was ich halt irgendwie aus dem Bauch raus entscheiden würde, sondern das muss halt schon, da muss man schon halt ein paar Gedanken machen, bevor man sowas anbietet im größeren Rahmen als für sich selbst.
Naja, größerer Rahmen ist es ja dann, ist es ja erstmal gar nicht. Das ist ja am meisten wahrscheinlich nur so, dass dann der eine sagt, so hier, könnte ich nicht auch mal so einen, keine Ahnung, On-Cloud-Account haben. Da wird es dann auch relativ einfach gemacht.
Weil da gibt es auch... Mit zehn Freunden, die auf einer Party sind, dann ist das irgendwie plötzlich so, ja, dann ist das von jeder Party sind da die Bilder drauf. Und dann plötzlich in einem Jahr so, ja, wieso geht denn das nicht mehr und...
Ja, man muss auch, also wenn man die Geschäftsbedingungen liest, die man da unterschrieben hat, dann ist, muss man auch dazu sagen, dass es meistens sowohl bei den ISPs als auch bei, also manchmal bei, selbst wenn man einen Hoste nimmt, sind da manche Dinge einfach komplett ausgenommen. Aus welchem Grund auch immer.
Inwiefern jetzt?
Na, also zum Beispiel bei den, also Telekom will dich, ein neues Beispiel, eigentlich zwingen, dass wenn du einen Server dritten anbietest, dass du da schon den Telekom Business Vertrag nimmst.
Also wenn ich zu Hause einen Server stehen habe?
Für dich selber ist das noch okay, aber wenn du das für dritte anbietest, dann ist das nicht mehr, hast du, ist, also, steht zumindest nicht in den Geschäftsbedingungen so drin, wie die du da bei deinem Vertrag unterschrieben hast.
Da kommen noch andere Dinge. Die Piratenpartei hatte da so einen Google Docs ähnlichen Service angeboten. Das ist so ein Etherpad heißt es. Und dort haben auch alle Leute drin Texte verfassen können. Und dann hatten sie plötzlich Probleme gehabt, weil wenn du Texte im Internet anbietest, dann stellst du sie zur Verfügung. Du veröffentlichst die und müsstest dann eigentlich in ein Impressum drunter packen und bist dann irgendwie auch, musst einen verantwortlich im Sinne des Presserechts benennen, der dann im Zweifel haftet dafür, dass dort Texte veröffentlicht werden auf deiner Webseite. Dass das allein schon der Betrieb von einem Etherpad-Server kann dir dann irgendwie rechtliche Schwulitäten noch bringen. Da musst du dann schon aufpassen, wie in der Accounts.
Also ich sag mal so, gerade wenn man sich in diesem Anfangsstadium befindet, dann ist es also eher so, nur mit sehr guten Freunden.
Ja im Zweifel irgendwie die mit hochrotem Kopf anzurufen und zu sagen, du, ach ja, übrigens wegen deiner Mail der letzten Jahre...
Also okay, nur mit sehr, sehr guten Freunden. Und denen sagt man auch, aber fürs Backup seid ihr selber zuständig.
Okay.
Gut, vor allem man guckt nicht rein. Also dann sollte...
Machen wir gleich.
Na gut.
Machen wir gleich? Erst mal Nachrichten. Mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Liebe Cottburser, wenn ihr die Sportfreunde Stiller schon immer mal Open Air sehen wolltet, dann reißt doch einfach das Dach von eurer Messehalle ab. Und liebe Berliner, wenn ihr die Sportfreunde Stiller lieber mit dem Dach drüber sehen wollt, dann baut halt eins über die Zitadelle. So oder so.
Fritz präsentiert.
Sportfreunde Stiller. Am Donnerstag den 29. Mai live in der Messe Cottbus. Und am Freitag den 15. August Open Air in der Zitadelle Spandau. Und Cottbus und Berlin. Sportfreunde Stiller. Zwei Mal live präsentiert von Fritz.
Immer gute neue Musik. Fritz Nachrichten.
Union und SPD haben sich auf einen Gesetzentwurf zur doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft für nicht EU-Bürger geeinigt. Kinder, die seit der Geburt neben dem Deutschen auch noch einen anderen Pass besitzen, sollen sich in Zukunft nicht mehr zwischen den beiden Staatsbürgerschaften entscheiden müssen. Voraussetzung ist, dass sie mindestens 8 Jahre lang in Deutschland gelebt haben oder 6 Jahre lang eine deutsche Schule besucht haben. Die Regelung gilt auch für Kinder ausländischer Eltern mit einem deutschen Schul- oder Ausbildungsabschluss. Nach dem Nachrichtendienst Twitter hat die türkische Regierung jetzt auch YouTube blockiert. Das melden staatliche Medien des Landes. Auf YouTube waren zuvor Tonaufnahmen aufgetaucht, auf denen angeblich der türkische Außenminister, der Geheimdienstchef und zwei weitere Spitzenbeamte zu hören waren. Die Männer sollen über eine militärische Intervention in Syrien gesprochen haben. Wie YouTube wurde auch Twitter in der Vergangenheit dazu genutzt, um Korruptionsvorwürfe gegen die Regierung von Ministerpräsident Erdogan zu verbreiten. Die UNO-Vollversammlung hat die Eingliederung der Krim durch Russland verurteilt. Für die Erklärung stimmten in New York 100 Staaten, darunter auch Deutschland. Elf Länder waren dagegen, fast 60 enthielten sich. In dem Text wird die internationale Gemeinschaft aufgerufen, keine Veränderung der ukrainischen Grenzen anzuerkennen. Der internationale Währungsfonds hat der Ukraine heute einen 27 Milliarden Kredit versprochen. Dafür müsste das Land aber strenge Sparmaßnahmen durchsetzen. Für Steuerbetrüger wird es künftig teurer und schwieriger, mit einer Selbstanzeige straffrei davon zu kommen. Die Finanzminister der Länder haben sich darauf geeinigt, die Regeln für die Selbstanzeige weiter zu verschärfen. Unter anderem soll der Zeitraum zur Offenlegung von 5 auf 10 Jahre verlängert werden. Außerdem sollen die Strafzuschläge auf hinterzogene Summen verdoppelt werden. Es sind aber noch Details offen, sie sollen bis Mai geklärt werden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Köpenick 4, Tempelhof 6 Grad, in Prenzlau 2, Falkensee und Wiesenburg und Karlau jeweils 5 Grad. Heute Nacht kann es in Richtung Oder und Neißen noch etwas regnen, der Rest von Brandenburg und Berlin bleibt aber trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken auf bis zu 1 Grad. Morgen gibt es dann wieder mehr Regen, nur etwas Sonne bei maximal 16 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin nach Tiergarten. Hier ist der Tiergartentunnel bis 5 Uhr früh in Richtung Wedding gesperrt. Und zur Berliner S-Bahn. Bis Betriebsschluss ist die Linie S5 zwischen Lichtenberg und Wuletal unterbrochen. Ihr könnt die U5 nutzen. Zudem werden zwischen Bießdorf und Wuletal Busse eingesetzt. Die Linie in S7 und S75 sind zwischen den Bahnhöfen Springfuhl und Lichtenberg unterbrochen. Ein Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen wird eingerichtet. Da, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo heute drei Leute vom Chaos Computer Club zu Gast sind, nämlich der Erdgeist, der Kai und Dmitry. Und die erzählen uns heute, wie man selber Dinge hosten kann. Das heißt, wie man Dienste, die eigentlich, die wir nur aus dem Netz können, wie man die selber betreiben kann. Wir haben schon gelernt, dass, warum man das tun sollte, was man dafür braucht, also was für Hardware man dafür brauchen, dass es sich lohnt, dass, wenn man anfängt, erst mal zu Hause am eigenen DSL zu betreiben. Wir haben gelernt, wie man das so ans Internet anschließt, dass man dann auch tatsächlich darauf zugreifen kann von überall. Und wir haben gelernt, dass es verschiedene Software-Wares gibt, die man benutzen kann, zum Beispiel On Cloud, zum Beispiel ReadyCode, zum Beispiel DevIcle, also verschiedene Sachen, die man auch alles nachlesen kann nach dieser Sendung unter chaosradio.ccc.de. So, und jetzt haben wir gerade noch zum Schluss drüber gesprochen, man hat jetzt so einen Service eingerichtet und man kann jetzt auf seinem ganz eigenen Computer, der im Netz hängt, zum Beispiel Dateien synchronisieren, zum Beispiel seine Kalenderdaten synchronisieren, zum Beispiel seine Kontaktdaten synchronisieren. Und Freunde sagen dann so, er kette das auch gerne oder man hat vielleicht sogar geschafft, einen Mailserver aufzustellen. Man hat jetzt über seinen eigenen Server, der also nicht nur für die eigene Webseite, wie das manche Leute sicher einrichten lassen, sondern wirklich auf der eigenen Maschine, kann man einen Mailserver machen, und dann hat er gesagt, da guckt man aber nicht rein. Das ist ja überhaupt so ein spannendes Ding, wenn ich jetzt so einen eigenen Service betreibe. Als Admin kann ich denn überhaupt immer reingucken oder kann ich das auch gleich so einrichten, dass ich gar keinen Zugriff habe auf das, was die User da machen?
Nee, nur eine Theorie. Also wenn du es selber einrichtest, kannst du im Zweifel auch immer reingucken. Also ich habe auf meinem Mailserver eine ziemlich restriktive Policy, was das Logging betrifft. Das heißt, alle halbe Stunde werden die Logs des Mailservers wieder gelöscht. Wenn irgendwas schief geht, kann ich schnell reingucken, dann sind die noch da. Ich könnte also mit einem Blick sofort sehen, welche Mails da reingehen und welche rausgehen. Und ich kann natürlich auch in die Inhalte reingucken. Ich meine, am Ende ist es nur Software, die auch in einem Betrieb verknüpft wird. Na selbst wenn sie verschlüsselt sind, muss ja damit sie... Also wenn die Mails selber mit PGP verschlüsselt sind, dann kann ich nur in die Metadaten gucken. Also ich sehe, wer wem gemailt hat. Aber kann die Inhalte natürlich nicht angucken. Aber wenn die Mail ganz normal, also nicht ganz normal, wenn die Mail einfach nur von einem Web-Mailer, sagen wir bei Google oder Web.de geschickt worden ist, dann kann ich dort auch natürlich in die Inhalte reingucken. Die liegen dann nämlich einfach im Dateisystem. Zwar verschlüsselt, aber ich hab den Schlüssel.
Als Mailserver-Betreiber sieht man auch mehr Daten als angezeigt werden im Mailclient sozusagen. Man sieht wirklich von welcher IP-Adresse, also vor allem, wenn man die Logs auswertet. Man sieht die IP-Adresse und teilweise die etere IP-Adresse. Also man kann auch wirklich orten, wo der Person wirklich zu dem Zeitpunkt war, als er diese E-Mail abgeschickt hatte.
Deswegen ist bei mir auch so, wenn mir Leute wirklich ganz doll nahe stehen, dann kommen die nicht auf meinen Mailserver, weil ich will mich am Ende auch nicht erklären müssen, dass ich die Möglichkeit hätte, dort in die Mails reinzugucken.
Aber das ist ja quasi dann fast schon so eine Art nicht zu kleines Problem, weil einerseits will man halt nicht irgendwo hingehen zu einem Mailserver, weil da weiß man gar nicht, was passiert, aber man will halt auch nicht zu Freunden gehen, weil es dann, das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an dieses bei Geld hört die Freundschaft auf.
Es ist anders, es ist so ein bisschen wie, warum diese NSA-Affäre erst so wenig Schub bekommen hat, ist es total egal, wenn irgendjemand ein Langley in deine Mails rein guckt oder bei der NSA, kenn ich nicht. Aber wenn der Nachbar in meine Post rein gucken kann, dann hört der Spaß auf, weil das ist dann irgendwie so in meiner Sphäre, die mich dann irgendwie so direkt betrifft. Und das ist, glaub ich, so dieser Effekt, den man dann da merken sollte. Jetzt da bei Web.de oder bei irgendeinem Mail-Hoster, wenn dort die Administratoren in meine E-Mails reingucken, ja hey, ich hab da nichts zu verbergen und die kenn ich nicht, so ist mir egal, dann sollen sie halt reingucken. Das ist dann so eher das Mindset, das einem begegnet, wenn man so mit Leuten spricht, die ihre Mails woanders liegen haben. Als auf meinem E-Mailserver.
Ich überlege gerade, ob es da noch so eine Möglichkeit hat, dass du sagst, du würdest halt Leuten, mit denen du wirklich sehr eng bist, keine E-Mail geben würdest, dann sagen, ich verweise dich aber gerne an hier Freund XY.
Das mach ich auch immer.
Okay, also sagen dann, dass es halt trotzdem noch auf diesem Eigenhosting quasi irgendwie läuft, aber das ist halt nicht die engste Schnittstelle ist. Dann noch eine andere Frage, weil wir haben am Anfang schon drüber geredet, dass man nicht nur zu Hause sich den Rechner hinstellen kann, sondern auch tatsächlich also einfach also Rechenkraft oder richtig Hardware in einem Rechenzentrum mieten kann. Und da ist es ja dann so, also es ist ja, wir haben ja auch schon besprochen, wenn man zu Hause hat dieses beruhigende Gefühl, der Rechner, der ist halt da. So, kann ich halt anfassen und ich kann insbesondere auch mein Zimmer abschließen, dann kann halt niemand da ran. Wenn ich jetzt in einem Rechenzentrum Hardware oder Rechenkraft miete, dann ist das ja schon wieder ein Dritter. Dann ist es zwar nicht Google, aber es ist halt irgendwo, irgendwo eine Firma. Können, haben die denn dann Zugriff auf meinen Rechner oder kann ich einen Rechner tatsächlich so einrichten, dass nur die Leute, die ein Login haben, da Dinge tun können?
Also du kommst, also es gibt halt verschiedenste Methoden. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du in einem Rechenzentrum halt einen richtigen Server, jetzt nicht irgendwie eine virtuelle Kiste gemietest, sondern wirklich einen physikalischen Server, dann kannst du den so rein theoretisch so aufsetzen, dass er zum Beispiel verschlüsselt ist, nur mit deiner Eingabe hochfährt oder so Sachen. Ist aber so ein bisschen grenzwertig, weil tatsächlich könnten die von vorne rein mit lauschen. Und wenn du 100% sicher gehen willst, dann kaufst du dir deine eigene Hardware, baust den selbst zusammen, setzt ihn zu Hause auf und trägst ihn dann selbst ins Rechenzentrum.
Und vor allem, es gab auch genug Fälle, wo zum, also sobald der Rechner hochgefahren ist, dann ist alles in dem Sinne, also vor allem, wenn man von einer verschlüsselten Betriebssysteme oder von verschlüsselter Partition spricht, dann wird alles erstmal entschlüsselt. Also und die, wenn man, wenn man Angst irgendwie hat von der Festnahme seines Servers, dann sind die jeweilige Behörden auch sozusagen schlau genug, um da mit dem Akku hinzugehen, so dass der Server nicht sich ausschaltet, wenn sie das mit sozusagen, mitnehmen einfach.
Aber wenn man, da sag ich halt so weit, wenn man solche Daten, die so gefährlich sind, auf den Servern lagert, dann sollten die erst gar nicht ins Internet, weil die sollten erst gar nicht anfallen zum Beispiel.
Naja, das kann man natürlich leicht sagen, aber andererseits ist es ja so, wir haben jetzt bei diesem ganzen NSA-Skandal gelernt, es wird nichts gemacht, was nicht technisch möglich ist. Wenn man jetzt sagt, setz dich einfach als maßgebend, ich möchte nicht, nehmen wir es einfach so, meine Kontaktdaten oder meine Kalender, die ich synchronisiere, ich möchte nicht, dass da irgendjemand in die Hände fällt.
Dann muss man entweder sagen, man steckt sich das zu Hause an einen Server, den man halt nur anmacht zum Synchronisieren. Oder man geht sogar den Schritt zurück und sagt, naja, dann muss ich halt mein Kabel wieder an den Rechner stecken. Aber wenn man es halt so tatsächlich on the fly immer synchronisiert haben will, dann muss man halt zu dem Punkt gehen, dass halt irgendeine Kiste immer online ist, immer erreichbar und damit auch immer angreifbar so gesehen.
Aber bei E-Mail, E-Mail explizit ist ein interessanter Fall, weil eigentlich gibt es da auch andere Lösungen. Denn wie viele E-Mails brauchst du eigentlich immer synchronisiert haben? Also vielleicht brauchst du die letzte zwei Wochen. Also könntest du theoretisch eine Server Instance irgendwo aufsetzen, wo du die letzte zwei Wochen E-Mail-Verkehr hast. Und ansonsten hast du sie nur lokal auf einem Rechner.
Oder einfach wie früher TM, wo man sie halt wirklich einfach abholt und dann hat man sie auf dem Rechner und fertig.
Genau das, nee, aber das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die man einfach sehr leicht aufsetzen kann. Meiner Meinung nach hat man ein Notebook und zwei mobile Geräte. Und das Notebook löscht halt die E-Mails, die auf dem Server sind, nach zwei Wochen. Und dann hat man gar nicht mehr dieses Problem, dass die jegliche Inhalte auf dem Server sind, sondern man weiß nur, dass zwei Wochen E-Mails auf dem Server sind.
Du merkst, dass wir 2014 haben, wie man sagt, du hast einen Laptop und zwei mobile Geräte.
Ich hab noch einen ganz wichtigen Punkt, der an der Stelle noch gar nicht zur Sprache kam. In dem Moment, wo du deinen eigenen Server irgendwo aufsetzt, hast du natürlich das Problem, dass du mit dem kryptographisch gesichert kommunizieren möchtest. Und allein die Basis, mit dem kryptographisch gesichert zu kommunizieren, ist, wenn du nicht gerade die Kommandozeile benutzt, also wenn du nicht den SSH Zugang darauf benutzt, ziemlich schwierig, weil die Art und Weise, mit denen zum Beispiel über den Browser zu sprechen, ist ja nur dadurch abgesichert, dass in deinem Browser so ein paar Zertifikate, sogenannte RUT-Zertifikate, mit ausgeliefert werden, wo du der chinesischen Regierung, der amerikanischen Regierung, der deutschen T-Systems, irgendwie der türkische Regierung, also sowieso alle mit dabei und alle können, weil sie als vertrauenswürdiges RUT-Zertifikat in deinem Browser eingebaut sind, können theoretisch jetzt, während du deinen Rechner administrierst oder während du einen dieser Dienste dort in Anspruch nimmst und dich dem Gegenüber authentifizierst, können sich in die Mitte hängen und deinen Dienst sozusagen mit übernehmen. Das können sie nicht nur bei dir, sondern jedem, dem du so einen Account mit in die Hand drückst. Und um einen verschlüsselten Dienst anzubieten, musst du dich sowieso erstmal darum kümmern, dass du selber so einen Zertifikat bei einem der Anbieter dir besorgst, um dann auch ernstzunehmend mit Kryptographie sprechen zu können. Da gibt es Dienste, die dir das kostenlos anbieten. Jetzt gab es gerade erst das, dass der Dienst CAs hört, der Zertifikate wirklich in der Community für umsonst rausgegeben hat, weil wenn du dem CA-Root-Zertifikat getraut hast, dann konntest du dir da einfach so ein Zertifikat klicken. Viele Nerdfreunde haben bestimmt auch das CA-Cert mit in ihrem Browser installiert. Es gibt aber auch Firmen, die für einzelne Zertifikate einfach kein Geld nehmen. start.com zum Beispiel ist so ein Dienst, wo man hingehen kann und sagen, gib mir mal einfach so ein Zertifikat, was wirklich nur für die Webseite ist, kann keines Subdomains, aber es stellt dir zumindest Zertifikate aus. Und mit dem sollte man sich auch auf jeden Fall grob beschäftigen, wie dieses SSL oder dieses HTTPS, wie das funktioniert und wie man dann in seinen Webserver solche Zertifikate reinwirft, damit man dann nicht gleich komplett unverschlüsselt mit seinem ins Internet gestellten oder zu Hause hingestellten Computer spricht, wenn man aus dem Internet unterwegs ist.
Ich kann nur empfehlen, falls euch für dieses Thema, also das ist tatsächlich noch mal eine ganz eigene Thematik, die sich spreche mit einem Computer verschlüsselt, Chaosradio 172, SSL oder einmal aufmachen bitte. Da haben wir das mal ausführlich gesprochen, also das kann man sich da noch mal reintun. Das heißt also, ihr sagt aber auch, wenn man sich langfristig mit dem Thema beschäftigt, dann sollte man bunte Software hin und her tatsächlich irgendwann dazu kommen, dass man über dieses SSH-Werkzeug mit dem Server kommuniziert, weil das einfach sozusagen sicherer ist als die SSL-Verschlüsselung.
Ich glaube, in meinen Augen kommt man nicht drumherum, einen Server wirklich irgendwo zu mieten. Also das Beispiel, das wir vor der Sendung besprochen haben, ist eigentlich, man kann gar nicht einen Server, einen Mailserver bei den allermeisten Anbieter zu Hause laufen lassen, weil sie gegen die Zwecke der Spam-Bekämpfung blockieren sie einfach die notwendigen Ports, die man braucht, um einen Mailserver in diesem Netz zu betreiben.
Oder wenn er offen ist und da eine Spam-Erkennungssoftware auf der Gegenseite läuft, die sagt, oh, der kommt von einem DSL-Anschluss, das ist doch bestimmt ein kompromittierter Rechner, ich gebe dem erstmal 10 Punkte und das ist definitiv Spam.
Genau, also man merkt, man schreibt seine Kollegen, die, also ja, man kann eigentlich ziemlich sicher davon ausgehen, man schreibt die, man hat alles aufgesetzt, es scheint alles zu funktionieren, die ganzen Testmails, man kann Testmails hin und her schicken, alles sieht super aus und man schickt eine E-Mail an seinen besten Kumpel, der gerade eine Gmail-Adresse hat und sagt, hast du das bekommen? Und der sucht das 15 Minuten und findet das im Spam. Und man schickt die nächste E-Mail und das landet wieder im Spam und man kommt gar nicht drum herum. Und der Grund ist eigentlich, man hat die falsche Wahl getroffen, wo diese Server eigentlich steht, nämlich in einem nicht vertrauenswürdigen Adressbereich aus Googles Sicht.
Mail ist auch nochmal schwierig, verstehe. Wo wir auch nochmal drüber reden müssten, und zwar, weil wir müssen uns jetzt schon wieder beeilen, wir sind auch gleich wieder vorbei. Aber trotzdem nochmal kurz die Frage, ihr sagt das ja eigentlich in fast jedem Chaosradio, wenn es um Java geht. Java, ein Chatprotokoll, wo es viele Clients für gibt, die relativ einfach zu bedienen sind. Und es gibt halt einen Java Server vom Chaos Computer Club, der sagt halt, also der machst du hier, so könnte das aussehen, die benutzen eigentlich alle. Also wenn du in Deutschland jemanden fragst, wo hast du deine Java Adresse? Und wenn das nicht Google ist, dann ist das meistens der CCC Server. Du sagst immer, ja dezentralisieren, mach doch mal selber so einen Server. Ist das denn auch sowas, was unter diesem Bereich fällt, wo ihr sagt, na hier, Java Server selbst hosten, das ist nicht schwierig, das kann man mal schnell machen?
Ja, also man kann das halt beliebig skalieren, aber umso den einfachsten, so damit man seine eigene Adresse oder seine E-Mail Adresse zum Beispiel als Java Adresse auch benutzen kann. Das ist nicht wirklich schwer, da gibt es halt wirklich How-To's ganz viele, die das wirklich beschreiben und das ist, ich würde mal sagen, eine halbe Stunde Arbeit maximal.
Ohne Vorkenntnisse, eine halbe Stunde Arbeit.
Wenn man es geschafft hat, dass man einen Rechner aufgesetzt hat und so administriert, dass zum Beispiel schon Mailserver läuft, also man sich so grundlegend zum Beispiel eine Linie auskennt, ist das nicht schwierig oder man geht wieder zum Beispiel zu dem Punkt, wo ich glaube Apple Server, also wenn man halt so ein Mac OS X Server installiert hat, kannst du da einfach klick iChat Server anmachen, was auch nur ein Java Server ist am Ende. Und dann macht er das auch. Und ja, das ist halt wirklich nicht schwer, den zu hosten, verbraucht unheimlich wenig Leistung, also und das spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen, wieso man es nicht machen sollte, sobald man Zugriff auf irgendwie einen ordentlichen Server, der irgendwo ein bisschen draußen steht und nicht hinter irgendetwas läuft.
Hatte auch viele Sicherheitslücken, muss man sagen, der klassische Jabberday.
Aha.
Ja, aber das benutzen wir ja auch nicht mehr.
Ausgerechnet, ausgerechnet, Synchronisation und Jabber-Server sind für mich die beiden Anwendungen, die man sehr, also die man eigentlich besonders gut dezentral auf so eine DSL-Leitung zu Hause hosten kann.
Und es ist halt einfach viel cooler, weil man dann nicht irgendwie erdgeist.gmail.org heißt, sondern erdgeist.erdgeist.org. Achso, und zwar der richtige.
Oh, jetzt blicken hier schon wieder die Freunde-Anfragen auf.
Er hätte ja nicht sagen müssen, dass es ziemlich gering ist.
Ich seh's halt bei mir, ich bin halt nicht auf Jabber.ccc.de, sondern auf dem etwas kleineren Berliner Server. Und jedes Mal, wenn Jabber.ccc.de irgendeine Wartung macht, seh ich so, oh, 200 der 100 Kontakte in meinem Jabber sind offline.
200 der 100, krass.
Also, es ist halt einfach eine riesige Menge, die halt dann doch wieder, obwohl es ein riesiges dezentrales Protokoll ist, wie er die gleichen drei, vier Services nutzt, man ist halt so, wieso nicht einfach mehr...
Das ist doch Quatsch, liebe Leute. Ja, so, macht das besser. Jabber.ccc.de aber aussetzen, ist ja also die Hausaufgabe. Was haben wir jetzt noch vergessen?
Files zünden haben wir da irgendwie oder so.
Ich würde noch mal auf so Admin-Ethik zurückkommen, gerade auf diese Freundesache so. So, wenn ich halt für Dinge, für Freunde hoste, dann heißt das so, also ist halt meine Perspektive Ethik, aber ich nehme halt zum Beispiel nicht, weil jemand meinen Mailserver mit nutzt, benutze ich das nie als Druckmittel, auch wenn ich die Person plötzlich abgrundtief hasse. Dann würd ich ihr vielleicht sagen, ja geh mal bitte, ich will dir nicht mehr helfen, aber dann sagen so, nee, ich nehm dir jetzt deine Mails weg und du musst jetzt das tun oder du musst wieder nett zu mir sein und mir ein Kuchen bringen, sonst kriegst du deine Mails nicht wieder.
Du meinst, du würdest nicht beratenbar teilmachen?
So wollte ich das jetzt nicht ausdrücken, aber das ist halt einfach so, du stellst halt einen Service bereit und egal was kommt, du nimmst ihn halt nicht als Druckmittel. Das gehört sich halt einfach nicht.
Muss man sich vorher überlegen, und wie lange man da Energie reinstecken möchte und wenn ich jetzt irgendwann mal sage, ich keine Ahnung, zähne die Karibik aus und dann würde ich auch sagen, so jetzt habt alle noch ein Jahr Zeit irgendwo hin umzuziehen. Ich helfe euch vielleicht noch Vertrauen, solche Services zu finden. Aber so von heute auf morgen aus machen ist einfach ein Unding.
Das sollte man sich dann auf jeden Fall auf die Fahne machen.
Und vor allem wenn der Erdgeist jetzt sagt, ich hab ihm gestern verlinke ich die Mate übers Notebook gekippt und deswegen nimmt er mir jetzt meine Mails weg, bis ich ihm ein neues Notebook gekauft hab. Das ist halt so ein Druckmittel, das ist halt super verlockend manchmal, aber das macht man halt einfach nicht.
Tatsächlich, um den Insider auch noch zu erklären, es war halt neulich, dass die Piratenpartei sich halt stritt. Dann haben halt die Leute, die für die Piraten die interne Infrastruktur machen, also die die ganzen Padserver glaube ich betreiben und die Webserver und die Mails und was auch immer, haben gesagt, wir streiten jetzt, wir machen die Technik aus. Und das ist halt so was, das macht man eigentlich nicht, weil da ging es um einen Partei-Internstreit. Ich hab mich mit einem von den Leuten, die da mit verantwortlich waren, auf Twitter unterhalten und er meinte, er weiß halt aber auch nicht mehr weiter. Also wenn man so einen Service für Freundinnen bietet, dann sollte man sich darüber am klaren sein, auch wenn man charakterfest genug ist, auch im schlimmsten Fall zu sagen, A, ich gucke da nicht rein und B, ich verwende das nicht gegen dich. Also wenn man jemand ist, der eh schon Probleme hat, Smartphones auf dem Tisch liegen zu lassen von Freunden.
Und wenn es dir halt nicht passt, dann sagst du halt, geh bitte oder ich biete dir den Service einfach nicht weiter an. Punkt. Aber halt irgendwie wegnehmen und sagen so, ich erpresse dich jetzt, damit es halt so ganz, ganz schlecht ist.
Also eine Sache, die wo ich gerade so ein bisschen rumspiele, ist ein VPN Server aufzubauen. Also dass ich eigentlich mich über VPN nach Hause einwählen kann und dann eben die Maschinen, die dort stehen und die Services, also die Server, die dort stehen, erreichen kann, ohne dass sie dem Internet sichtbar sind. Und dann bin ich diese ganze Problematik mit, ich kann eigentlich ohne Cloud nicht ganz vertrauen, bin ich los, weil man kann diesen Server nur erreichen, wenn man diese sehr komplizierte Konfiguration, die wenige Schwachstellen hat. Also das wird man nicht einfach ohne... Also man wird einfach diese Hosts, also dieses Server gar nicht erreichen können.
Also um das noch kurz zu erklären, wir haben es vorhin schon mal kurz erklärt, VPN, da ging es um andersrum. Da ging es darum, dass man sagt, naja, man kann das so machen, dass man von außen immer zur selben Adresse geht und dann sozusagen bei sich zu Hause landet. Man kann es auch dazu benutzen, dass man sich von außen, wo auch immer man sich im Internet einloggt, dass man sich erstmal in dieses VPN einloggt und dann ist das quasi so, als wäre man zu Hause im heimischen Netzwerk. So, und diesen Service kann man auch damit machen.
Ich bin die ganze Zeit überlegen, weil tatsächlich bin ich privat weniger Service maintainer und gibt es halt einfach nicht. Weil ich halt einfach sage, ich mache es halt auf Arbeit, Dinge zu administrieren und Netze zu betreiben. Privat will ich halt einfach inzwischen so, ich will da mich nicht mehr drum kümmern müssen. Wenn eine Security-Lücke rauskommt, will ich nicht mehr wissen, Mist, ich sitze jetzt das Wochenende da und muss mein Mailserver updaten. Dann soll ich einfach sagen, also Mailserver und das war's eigentlich, weil ich es privat betreibe, ich würde mir jetzt nicht mehr antun, weil ich einfach das nicht will und halt die Verantwortung gerade keine Lust drauf habe.
Ich bau gerade zu Hause an meinem kleinen Bastel-Atom-Rechner rum und werde dann einen Plex installieren. Das ist eine clicky-bunt, die Oberfläche, die so ein bisschen ist, was man von Apple kennt, wenn man da irgendwie auf diese Menütaste drückt, wo man dann in so einem Karussell sich den Film oder die Serie oder so aussuchen kann, die da auf der Festplatte rumliegt und noch ein bisschen meine ganze verstreute Hardware konsolidieren. Ich hab da ja vorher so einen kleinen Rechnerzoo gehabt mit einem selbst aus Holz zusammengebauten Kasten, in dem die Festplatten da drüben stehen. Jetzt einmal schon alles richtig und mehr Strom sparen, und deutlich weniger Hardware-Tierchen, die da so Dinge tun.
Es ist eigentlich so, dass man, ich habe den Eindruck, wenn man sich das anguckt, diese ganzen Sachen, dass es momentan noch so ist, das gibt dieses On-Cloud und dann noch so ein paar Projekte. Aber dieses hier einklicken und ich installiere das auf einem Rechner, hat das eine Zukunft? Also ist es möglicherweise zeitlich später so, dass wir alle einfach so boxen, kaufen oder nehmen können und dann sagen können, hier stelle ich die zu Hause hin, habe da alle meinst.
Der Tom, der eigentlich heute mit mir sein wollte, aber leider krank ist, der bastelt gerade genau an sowas, wo einfach nur man in so ein Skript eine IP-Adresse eintragen muss und dann spielt er einem sowas wie diese Images, die wir davon besprochen haben, auf und tut das aber selber aus den Softwarepaketen und sorgt dann auch dafür, dass die Festplatte ordentlich verschlüsselt ist und obendrauf der Dienst auch immer aktualisiert wird. Der bastelt auch gerade sowas, dass es für den einfachen Heimanwender zu Hause kurz die Konsole aufmachen, einen Befehl eintippen, IP-Adresse angeben und schwupps hat man den Service installiert. Mit schön dokumentiert, auch für den Anfänger. Also als auch extra für dich, Markus. Als Early Adapter.
Schön, dass du das noch so gesagt hast.
Nee, im Chat kam auch gerade noch das Thema auf, wo lese ich denn überhaupt über Security-Lücken. Und gerade wenn man halt einen Service z.B. ins richtige Internet dann stellt, muss man sich halt natürlich darum kümmern, dass der dann sicher bleibt. Und in der Regel gibt es halt von den Produkten bzw. den Projekten, die halt so eine Software bauen, so Announce-Mailing-Listen oder eine Webseite, wo halt einfach drauf steht, dass eine neue Release rauskommt. Also da sollte man halt definitiv hin dranbleiben, weil das kann halt schon so ein bisschen gefährlich werden, wenn dann irgendwie halt diverse Fotos, die jetzt ein bisschen privater sind vielleicht, irgendwo liegen und du hast eine 3 Jahre alte Software, die sperrangelweit offen ist inzwischen, wo jeder drauf zugreifen kann. Und da muss man schon schauen, dass immer die aktuellste Version dann drauf ist, damit es sicher bleibt.
Das wollte ich auch noch mal sagen. Also was man natürlich auch noch machen kann ist, gerade wenn es um Datei-Synchronisation geht, da hindert dich natürlich niemand dran, wenn du deinen eigenen Service aufgeholt hast, dann noch mal das extra zu verschlüsseln. Also zum Beispiel mit sowas wie TrueCrypto oder Boxcrypto oder was es da alles gibt. Das kann man ja trotzdem auch noch machen.
Genau, aber was ist das halt eigentlich nicht mit einmal installieren getan, sondern das ist halt wie so ein Auto. Dann musst du halt auch mal irgendwie die Reifen wechseln, das Öl nachfüllen.
Es ist halt ein Bastelhobby.
Ja, man muss es halt einfach regelmäßig pflegen, sonst geht es halt ein wie eine Pflanze.
Das ist wirklich demotivierend für mich, denn ich habe einen schwarzen Daumen. Aber vielleicht klappt das ja mit der Software besser als mit den Pflanzen.
Aber wenn es darum geht, zum Beispiel Dateien zu synchronisieren, empfehle ich eigentlich jedem. Also wenn man eine Fritzbox beispielsweise zu Hause hat, dann bietet das sogenannte NAS, also Network Estatched Storage Funktion. Also man kann sich auch von verschiedenen Festplattenhersteller auch solche kleine Boxen kaufen, die eine Festplatte da drin haben, über die man auch irgendwie Dateien sharen kann und so weiter. Und das ist eigentlich der viel einfacher ist, sich das alles selber aufzusetzen.
Aber es macht nicht so viel Spaß.
Nee, das stimmt schon. Also man kann es schon wesentlich mehr machen mit so einer Raspberry Pi, ist ja wirklich ein kleiner Rechner.
Okay, also wenn ihr das gerne mal ausprobieren wollt, dann habt ihr jetzt genug Motivation und genug Anfangspunkte hier im Chaosradio gehört. Es ist mir noch aufgetragen worden, auf eine Veranstaltung hinzuweisen, außer Reichweite, die ein kleines Barcamp, wo es darum geht, dass am 5. April sich mal Leute zusammen setzen und wirklich rausfinden wollen, was man denn machen könnte gegen diese ganze Überwachung, ohne sich in politischen Flügel kämpfen zu verlieren.
Für den am 5.
April statt, außerreichweite.de war die Adresse. Ich würde mich jetzt verabschieden, dass er dennhalb noch einen kurzen Termin zu sagen. Oder noch Werbung für Projekte. Ansonsten kann man jeden am meisten Donnerstag, was sagt ihr mal, Donnerstag abends im Chaosradio ist? Also jetzt gerade kann man in den Chaos Computer Club in der Marienstraße 11 gehen. Mal gucken, was die Leute dort so treiben. Diese Sendung wird uns noch als Podcast geben. Auf fritz.de und möglicherweise auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de Nach uns kommt Hendrik Schröder mit dem Nightflight und wird euch mit Punkmusik bewerfen. Eine Sache war da noch. Erdgeist, Kai und Dmitry, vielen Dank fürs dabei sein.
Und verschlüsselt schön eure Backups. Was der Erdgeist sagt.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.